welcome everybody to the final speed
chess championship grand prix
i'm grand master robert hess and i'm
going to bring you the call today
it is our typical you know title tuesday
speeches championship grand reaction
the format as we will remind you is
what's in every tuesday three minute
plus one second increment
time control it is a ten round swiss
tournament the top
eight finishers advance to the knockout
bracket
and there's a lot of prize money at
stake each week
a thousand dollar first place prize it's
no surprise that hikaru nakamura has won
the lion's share
of these events but other people have
done quite well thus far
in their attempt to qualify for the
speed chess championship and you can see
all the way down
uh the quarterfinals make 100 top female
player and the top streamer also get 100
and to remind everybody about the
scoring system because this is a
qualifier for the main speeches
championship the base points are their
swiss score out of 10
it's whatever you scored in those 10
rounds then if you win the knockout you
get 12 bonus points and that
we'll talk more about that because it's
going to play a very important role
as we will have four qualifiers making
their way
into the speed chest chamber you see on
the graphic in front of you
the bottom right hand side there four
players from the sec
grand prix will make their way the
speeches championship there was the
super swiss
which vladimir feroceaev took a spot and
there's the jscc which nihal tsarnaev
won and later we will have the speed
chess championship invitational
but i mentioned vladimir putin and
that's particularly important because if
you look at the standings
on the screen in front of you you will
see that vladimir putin is in third
place
in the sccgp hikar nakamura is in first
but he is the reigning speeches
champion speed chess championship
champion or can i just say speeches
champion
i don't know but you know what i'm
talking about hikaru did win that so he
already is qualified
federsev qualified by virtue of
finishing second to
hikaru in the super swiss so that leaves
four spots
up for grabs artemyev looks like he's
locked himself up a spot
no surprise there he is one of the best
players on this planet
then you have nordivec abducitarov who
fell short in the jscc but has been a
mainstay
of the knockout brackets here in the
speeches champion grand prix
series then you have parham maksudu
right behind nordivec
he looks like he is in good shape to
qualify and then that's where it gets
tricky hike marti rosian would be the
fourth qualifier
had we not had one more speeches
championship grand prix and players like
alireza faruja who okay let's be real
i'll get an
invite whether or not he qualifies by
virtue of this
uh grand prix you have maxim chigayov
maxime vashiola grav
and we also have tuamenlei the
wonderful international master from
vietnam wonderful time
they all have a chance because you get
their base points from the swiss
then you get bonus points in the
knockout which means that all of these
players are within
striking distance and well i would say
without further ado we will have
uh the action but we still have a minute
so let's talk about some of the players
in the field today
hikaru of course taking part we have uh
vladimir ferrissev that is big fish
1995. he really gave
hikar all he could handle in the super
swiss that's the name that you'll want
to keep an eye on
there's arjun aragasi and the number
three seed
then there's nuribeck abuse he's going
to lock up his spot he'll make his way
to speeches championship proper
and number five that's one of the
players we're going to keep an eye on
today
is the beast from lyon that is maxime of
shayla grav
we mentioned that he is on the outside
looking in okay we also figure that he
probably will get an invitation
regardless
i don't know the invites but he is
maxine vashila grub after all he's a top
10 player in the world
and it doesn't really feel like a
speechless championship without his
participation
but he could qualify directly by taking
the fourth spot away
from a player like hayek martirosian i
do not see hike's name here
on the listed entrance for today's sec
gp
so that is going to be an interesting
storyline going forward uh right behind
maxime is fair chess on youtube that is
dimitri on draken
a super strong russian grandmaster he is
a super grand master he's also a
speed chess specialist if you will so
it's nice to be 2700 plus feed a
classical
and still be considered a speed chess
specialist we have le quang liam there
behind him giga cooperative he's strong
georgian grand master ronin said moani
parham well we said he's number three
and he will lock up his spot for
qualification
there's um martinez from peru jaspham
we have azeri chest which is the one and
only chakra mama jarov
msb2 that is matthias bluebaum from
germany
alexander zubov and then we have an
international master from
uh peru ronaldo terry lujan and just by
doing these events so much
i can just look at a username and i know
exactly who that participant is um
it's just you get familiar with these
people week in and week out
and i've had the pleasure and privilege
of playing many of them
myself so we do have liftoff let us
start at the top
because why not we'll start with
hikaru's game he has the black pieces
in the opening round taking on a 2500
player so
no easy matches in the speeches
championship grand prix
every single round we'll see a super
grandmaster like a car
take on a very strong blitz player and
here hikaru
adopts the setup of a karo khan that
looks like it's mixed with
an alien defense and you have these
double f pawns which don't look very
good
at some point you do play f5 try to open
up this bishop but look at the car and
go he is just
lightning quick knows what he wants play
a4 put this bishop on e6 take over the
diagonal so if i were white
i'd probably a3 to keep my bishop on
this diagonal as even though it's not
the end of the world for the bishop to
get kicked to c2
what is that bishop doing there and he
actually voluntarily plays it which
surprises me
because it's staring to a brick wall of
a pawn structure
with uh the f7 g6 h7 configuration so
i like this opening for hikar i think he
has obtained a very good position one
that he feels comfortable with
and that he should just play without
real risk because the bishop on c2 now
feels quite misplaced and this bishop
comes right to e6
in a moment's notice taking over
important light squares here
from e6 all the way to c4 uh it looks
like white is thinking in this game
we'll
move on over to some others for now just
to see what's going on
okay b3 doesn't actually attack anything
by the way because the knight does
protect
a4 so let's keep on moving let's go to
peters fiddler why not
we love ourselves some peter's fiddler
action in the sec gp
and his opponent and national master has
his bishop on g4
and more importantly now the bishop on
b6 that's an open
diagonal and so white is going to have
difficulty castling here i think that
peter would like to
replace this bishop with his knight
because if you can envision the knight
on c4 it attacks the queen and attacks
the bishop
but that's very hard to accomplish
especially with let's put this queen
in green because it's a good piece and
the bishop on f5 you are staring down
the center of the board so it's more
likely a knight is going to go to the e4
square
which is just going to be a good move
and developing move and clogging the
center here but for the time being
white's king stuck in the center that
does
leave me a bit nervous about peter's
chances but he is peter svidler the
eight-time russian champion
the commentator extraordinaire and a
friend of mine
i have faith in his ability to handle a
position like this and
g4 g4 almost made me knock my own
glasses off because you don't expect
a move like g4 but can he go after this
bishop and he does
so he's trying to go h5 right now no
knight e4 first i guess
h5 can happen in the near future you can
also play g5
use this pawn h6 as a hook to pry
open the king's side so peter
is i see the bar just jumping up in his
favor it does look like
quite a nice position now i wasn't
expecting g4 but he is more familiar
with these positions than i am
and is it time for g5 that's the the
answer is
clearly yes definitively yes and i
would not be happy on the black side of
this position
no no no no the king is about to be
opened
uh you can put a rook on g1 to use the g
file
i see the bar continuing to just go
crazy over here you can probably take
this
uh bishop on h7 if need be
amongst other moves i mean the position
is looking so so good here
and oh playing g6 that doesn't look good
that can't be good freeze up control
over the
f6 square as well and okay if i can take
you on g7 and then swing over the h file
looks like there could be just mates
maybe take on d5
bring the rook off the last rank and
then take me on g7 instead because queen
issue first
to take on g7 next and in comes this
queen let's say
on this one to the end of the game
because we may see just see a
resignation or a checkmate
in the next few turns and svidler out to
a blazing hot start down the age file
look at these pieces lined up here
and i like that he didn't rush to take
on g7 i was advocating for that move it
almost certainly was a good decision but
there are times where
you can't take a decision like that back
and it could backfire so
instead he puts his queen and rook on
the opening h file
he will take on g7 and that's just going
to be a
very swift victory for him if you play
f6 well you're walking into a pin
but you're also allowing me to capture
on g7 anyway because i'm opening the h
file
queen takes me by knight e6 with the oh
gosh it's a cruncher
look at the fork here hitting the queen
and both rooks
well you can't survive this no no way
knight takes f8 actually wins a piece
because if the rook takes an f8 you lose
this knight on d5
if okay it takes this way because f6 is
hanging also wins a piece everything
wins
that's the benefit of having this
position first fiddler i was
and there's a resignation i was saying
that taking here works because you take
with the rook you lose the knight
directly
if you take with the king instead you
lose this bishop on h7 so
all roads were victorious for svidler he
takes down
his opponent let's move on over to
maxime vashila grav the beast from leon
with the black pieces here this is
actually quite a complex a rich position
where black is down two pawns but look
at these open
lines here for black's pieces this could
amount to a huge attack and wipe down to
18.9
seconds however the two extra pawns if
you're not careful
they can make their presence felt with a
series of trades so queen h extract the
king is going to go to e7 but watch out
for knight
f5 check because the point is that this
pawn is needed to protect the bishop
the king drops to h1 i'm already looking
for putting a piece
of some sort on d6 and going rook h8 but
that seems hard to accomplish
queen takes on f6 so if i could get your
bishop to move
that would be a checkmate but he drops
his bishop back to e7
where's his queen going queen f4 perhaps
all right
and bishop g5 is possible but you may
walk into a pin because
the rook on jeet is not defended so
you'd have to walk your king up to keep
it defended
or to make a difference i should say so
knight p5 is tempting to me at some
point
just to bring this knight into some of
these dark squares and get after this
king on the eight that's not a very safe
king
so in the very first game it looks like
maxine
he's trying to fend off his opponent uh
an armenian player
almost 2500 and knight f5 is always
going to be tempting but not quite yet
your queen is hanging so queen e5 played
first now knight f5 is serious
the e pawn is pinned because otherwise
you take this bishop on e7
there will be ideas of getting this
bishop on d5 so rook g5 played in queen
v8 check then rook back to c8 okay so
hanging on
for now is maxime and two seconds once
barely got the move off 92 barely in
time there
and this knight can re-route to f4 to
get after this pin bishop that looks
like one of the ideas here
rook c8 played the queen has to retreat
and barely got that move of 2.4 seconds
left
this is getting close with bishop c5
less queen f6 you won't allow that queen
to get after the f7 pawn
so that would be a mistake and it feels
like the movie you want to play is this
bishop move but
not in time so king e8 played knight f4
i expect okay
one maybe they move with 0.1 seconds
just flagged the guy
queen c4 queen aj check king here knight
takes d5 was possible
and queen a1 rerounding the queen to
come over to a7
rook takes g3 what a move rook hey check
oh the queen could take it
oh young he hung it but he didn't see it
oh my gosh she got lucky there and now
there must be some tactics by taking on
h3 so like queen
to c6 or queen b3 i was looking at
trying to take on h3 on f3
so bishop's seven queen d4 2.4 seconds
left still for white
queen g oh queen g a check that's it
that's it
and maxine wins on time in a position
where his opponent can
check him and win the rook oh my gosh
now that is the type of finish that we
love to see in the sec gp because queen
ga check
says thank you for your rook you're not
actually checking me kingdom
i don't know king d7 i guess to try to
be safer but after here queen g3
the king can just go to g1 and that's
only one check my king can start
escaping out that way
so that was a missed shot by white
maxine moves on
he wins the game and he keeps his
chances of qualifying from this alive
so many more games to go let's tune in
to this one it is
a bishop of same color ending which is
bad news for the defensive side and
that's vladimir on ashoka very strong
ukrainian grand master
he looks like he's going down to his
opponent here unless
he can get enough counter play and he
loses on time so
no counter play for him that's just a
loss on the clock
let's keep on going this is gawain jones
has how many queens
two queens i think that's enough and
queen e5
check take my queen i take yours let me
simplify this into an easily winning
position
where it's one extra queen still but now
white has no more pieces left and
okay wild tricks going for some tricks
but rook f7 check
okay work up six majors happening here
good game going jones too strong enough
to convert that one
and we're getting down to the finish
line here
okay this is a pawn that are you going
to be able to get it kg4
there are some opportunities to draw
positions like this but knight f4 is met
by rook to g8 check
which means that white would win and
king f6
knight uh oh knight h5 knight back and
then you go knight h5 and the knight
back tower just don't take the pawn
because as soon as you take the pawn the
king will come to g6 and take advantage
of the pin knight
wait they're just repeating so king of
seven do not take the pawn
do not take this pawn because the king
g6 happens but this is
going to be a draw wow what a hold
that is one of those cool rook h5 it's
really one of those cool end games that
you don't get to see all the time
where even though white is an exchange
up and with an extra pawn
there's no way to make progress as this
knight goes back and forth and if this
knight comes with a check and the king
comes to e5 you still do not take this
pawn taking the pawn whilst king to f5
and then the king has to go away from
the knights you just have to be careful
about your timing
and we are in the second round hikaru
nakamura gets the white pieces here
so he is going to try to make it two out
of two a perfect score
and thanks to everybody who's tuning in
really appreciate it
um here we go hikaru in the second game
uh let's uh
stay away from the car for now because
we will obviously look at
way more hikaru later in this event we
sort of anticipate most often that he
will be making his way
to the knockout stages just because he's
that good and let me uh
pull ups maybe some of our streamers
because we
do have uh plenty of
our streamers taking part in this so let
me find one
for us to follow let's uh
let's go to chelsea monaco's game
because it is the second round of action
here
um she has drawn her first game which
almost certainly would have been upset
and now she is playing
playing somebody nearly 2 700. so
we have uh her stream like we can
pull it up and well right now white has
more control over the board look at
these pawns advanced everywhere
and we see her calculating right now i
like this setup
that's a i like the pawn the chess.com
background
it uh looks pretty clean and her
position
is a bit of a struggle but she
is a capable player that's for sure
and she'll try to combat her opponent's
aggressive
pawn pushes and try to keep the position
locked up and i think that's her best
chances
if the position remains locked up and
white isn't time to
crash through that gives her enough
time here to reroute her pieces to
reorganize but it still looks pretty bad
so i think that her position
isn't so great here
and that's why she's sitting and
thinking
so let's uh maybe go out to another
streamer we have
badur jibawa taking part in this
tournament see him there
and baidura is such a fun player he's
playing entertaining games no matter who
his opponent is he could play magus
carlson
he could be playing against me he could
be playing against a
1200 you know that his games are going
to be a lot of
fun and in this one look at him drawing
arrows for us talking about that bishop
on f4
moving in both directions he's let's
look out for the h6 pawn
because that queen on g3 does pin the
pawn on g7
so bishop takes h6 could be the next
move
and he's still calculating where to move
his king he wants to
make sure he does not drop a pawn
especially one in front of his
king side that would be important and
i can only imagine what he's saying i do
like his
streaming setup as well by doris just
he's a funny guy
but okay he uh we'll leave him to figure
that out
we'll come back in with our buddy
vladimir ferrosev because he has just
played a
very interesting move g5 in what looked
like
a calm innocuous position he plays g5
trying to open up the king side
as his opponent has a really solid
foundation here look at white's pawn
structure safe and sound
we have a pawn chain going to d4 we have
a semi-open e file the semi-open c file
doesn't really amount to anything just
yet so i do prefer
a white's position here but we'll see
how federal state handles this
and well while we're talking about
streamers we remiss not to include the
biggest
chess streamer not named ludwig that is
hikaru nakamura
and we see a car trying to figure out
this position from the white side
he is a pawn ahead and
black is trying to close down the
position but here comes b5
for hikaru just trying to rush that pawn
up
and create a past fun of his own so even
if it costs him a pawn it may
still be worth it and i like his dual
cam
setup there so you can see hikaru very
directly from in front of him but also a
side cam just checking out his monitor
and he's been
a big advocate of this setup to
ensure that there is no fair play
violations that way you can see the
screen you can see
the player um i'm a fan of the setup and
of course a fan of hikaru because he is
just
an absolutely brilliant chess player and
he is taking the streaming world by
storm
tsm mccarron excuse me i misspoke and
look at him go he is breaking through
there
on the queen's side so his opponent
didn't actually
capture him b5 and i think he made a
wise choice he's trying to lock up the
position so if hikar for some reason
played the move a5
that would probably be a mistake because
the white king
should try to get to a5 like that's one
of the ideas but he's playing on both
sides of the board
principle of two weaknesses h5 rook to
g1 you can
go from flank to flank and this e pawn
is also a pass pawn so there's no way
for black
to close this position down that's what
he wants to do is
put a piece on b7 put it put rook on b7
put a king on e6 and say you can't make
any progress
but a car was just claiming yes i can
here comes the h-bomb that's
take it if you want i'm jettisoning that
pawn and i'm trying to open up another
flank of attack and here comes the rook
which means that
white is making progress and in fact
black just resigned that's a
knot of respect to an elite player
and a card nakamura goes to two and up
so let's go to
alina kashunskaya she took part in the
i'm not gm speeches championship she was
a finalist
she unfortunately for her lost in the
finals to john bartholomew
a fan favorite and what's going on here
looks like there's trouble down the c in
the d
lines there could be a checkmate for
black if white
is not careful but somehow all of these
important squares are under white's
control so there is no mate yet
and said min goes right after
this knight on b6 and queen takes b4
does not work i was mentioning i need to
watch out for
a check down here so bishop takes b5
and white does have two pieces for the
rook
so after eight takes b5 if the queen
takes b4 happened you could take on b6
but you're only getting
the two pieces back for your rook and
bishop c5 now
b6 is hanging behind that b5 is hanging
but look at this at the end of the day
you take c5 i take b5
and now it's in exchange up for black
nice transition white does have an extra
pawn for that exchange
so if she can stabilize her forces on
the queen side perhaps get this pawn to
b4
it's not going to be so easy for black
to make progress here and i like the
move b4
and the point is that if we trade rooks
how are you going to go after my pawns i
think that you have enough time to play
f6 king f7 and rook h8 in the event of
an exchange of rooks and
how do you exchange rooks you could have
started with rook to d2 instead
he's just going to go king f7 and he
leaves this
open rook h8 and once rookie shade
happens you play g5 you need to actually
create
problems for your opponent and he
actually has accomplished just that
although allowing the pawn to go to b6
feels a little bit
like a mistake wait rook takes v6 a free
pawn
i guess it wasn't dragging the pawn
results in a simple win of the pawn and
here he goes
he is up in a clean exchange he can
bring his king in and that should be
the end of the game so
yeah this is going after this pawn white
is going to try her best to hang on here
but now
f5 is even possible that's what you want
to do is take over the light squares
your king can infiltrate in light
squares
and that's a not a very good bishop
trying to hold it off and he's going to
bring his king to h5
and then white will be in swan can't
keep the king on h3 forever and then
comes the kingdom g4
f4 h4 one of them both of them are
falling and that's a win
for black so let's keep on going down
the list of games here we have plenty
remaining
why don't we go to this game here
jostling with the white pieces it
shall be a win for him look at that
bishop d4 that is just a
a little precision there take my bishop
that way my pawn goes free
and i don't have to give you my pawn so
i'm going to play h5 if oh actually h5
could backfire if you're not careful so
what
uh black is hoping for is to trade off
some pawns and win
the well okay it's irrelevant now
because
here comes this pass pawn that was just
very fine technique
by grandmaster martinez from peru let's
keep on going down the list so many
games
still underway it's what happens when
there's a tournament of nearly 600
players
uh why don't we go oh
there are two past pawns but there's a
good bishop
covering these this diagonal so check
can i start
pushing my a pawn i don't think you're
in time to do that the rook can always
swing to a8
and now you can just get a queen uh-oh
be careful if you move the bishop f7
happens
so that was important with king e6 where
he win the rook
and now white is an exchange ahead this
is a drawn position rook against bishop
but just bear kings remaining besides
those pieces that is a draw but not
always easy to accomplish
when you're in time trouble
so i think this one shall be a draw
we'll see if
uh there will be a hold here and i just
saw another result it looks like
the beast from leon maxine virtually was
held to a draw in his game
so we'll he'll need to bounce back
and score a lot of points can't afford
too many
splits in this one oh king is in the
corner watch out for that
this is i hold because if the bishop
comes to h7
and the rook's on the age file there's a
stalemate so bishop you would love to
just keep the rook
as a stamina exactly what i'm saying
normally if you were on a different line
you would be able to push the king but
there's no space off the side of the
board right there's the boundary so
that's just a stalemate
the king on f7 doesn't help you win the
piece it just actually helps create the
snail mate
all right so let's keep on going here we
have probably a few games remaining
we have a completely winning rook end
game up two pawns is
white and plenty of time 15 seconds no
big deal just uh
cruising so a two and a half score is
liam brolic and
you bring your king in push the pawns c5
now
yikes and that's just a resignation
and i believe that was our final game of
the round let me check no we actually
have one more
oh gosh rook and bishop against rook now
that's a pain to hold in any time
control
but especially blitz i do think that
white very likely
will win this game the king is already
in the corner here nope rook takes
bishop as soon as i say that rotates
bishop the rook
oh misses it you could just take in that
bishop because the rook would have been
able to block on h5 now rookie six check
your king has to go back up to h5 and
this is going to be no fun you can't go
king h6
rook comes here to block on h6 in the
case of rook h7 check
so rook and bishop vs rook it strikes
again king h6 you want to bring the king
to g7
good idea king could come right back to
uh
h5's necessary watch out ooh the king is
close to being instead th7 is possible
nope that's the wrong way that's wrong
you have to know that you can
you have to walk into the discovery
because the king and rook are so close
together there's no discovery against it
and here it comes
yeah this is a win it's a win oh boy
oh boy you need to know your
rookie bishop vs rook end game is very
difficult i was saying that
in the duress of time trouble
but you have to know what you can get
away with and after
oh new game started okay don't have
enough time to show everybody the ins
and outs of the rook ambition versus
rook but learn that end game especially
if you're a more advanced player this
will be happening in your games more
often
so we have the chess warrior that is
rudy beckham bruce taurev but let's take
a moment and give a shout out to anna
crumling who is taking part in this
tournament
very popular streamer always
entertaining i've commentated with her
before
she's uh just such a good person
always always in an upbeat mood honestly
so
fun to watch her channel do check it out
and
we do have many many streamers taking
part we have andrew tang
always on cloud nine these days he is
playing in this one looks like he's at a
perfect 2-0 score
so give the penguin gm one the penguin
gm one i just want to call him the
penguin gm but i know there's a numeral
i'm not a numeral just a number in his
name so it's hard to say
just give the penguin some love he
deserves it and he is
signed to a big esports work so
uh yeah let's uh
keep on going here as we continue
looking at this game between
nordibekker musatarov and wannabe
2700 and we see that white has this
knight on e5
protected by a stonewall like structure
of d4 and f4 pawns
but as is typical here the issue is the
e4 square is available to block this
knight comes to d6 and that comes into
e4
and black can eventually play pawn to f6
in a way that white cannot because white
has advanced these pawns to d4 and f4
which leaves the e4 square as a
vulnerable spot so black can push upon
four once the knight was at the way
white cannot push upon back to cover e4
so that's the advantage i would give
to black in this position but white is
still very
solid so even if you get one square the
e4 square
you still have a lot to prove after that
so uh
not the most interesting of games just
yet we will
probably see more of nerdy beck as time
goes on but let us
uh move on to some other games i always
like to
hop around as much as i can so we'll go
here to
seo robert i did not pick this game
because the person is robert in their
handle but i did see lamlay
taking part and even though black's pawn
structure is double this is actually an
advantage for black and you could think
about it what happens when you double
pawns
it means that there is an open line for
your pieces
because there would have been a d pawn
it captured on c5 or on c6 wherever it
captured like them
uh actually let me look at this
scoresheet to see where it did capture
because i would say likely on c6 if this
were from the spanish
but now i see took on c5 directly so
watch out here
oh gosh this is just a huge
problem i think that white's already
toast this these light squares
knight f3 check you might have to play
e4 or knight d5
but can i just take it and he does
because after queen takes e4 now i take
your pawn e4
that's a big issue you have to try to
block me
from getting on the diagonal but i just
take on e4 and the point is that your
rook on d2 is hanging
so this rook we're on d1 this wouldn't
work out quite as nicely for black but
because the rook is on d2 it's
left under attack e4 i take it and i can
move my knight back or if you take me
back on e4 and win your rook on d2 and
black has
scooped off two pawns for his troubles
temporary sacrifice netting material so
if not e4 okay now knight h3 and queen
each one's mate
gosh i'm sorry seo robert
that wasn't good that was good you need
to turn yourself more to ceo robert and
show
lamela who's boss let's go circuit
karjakin what did i just
turn into here karjakin with the white
pieces it is his move the king
just went no what okay e5 was by c
the e seven square was highlighted and i
was like well what just happened
but e7 e5 so this stems from some kind
of
bizarre queen e5 f6 giving up the c5
pawn
and then playing e5 so black is trying
to finish the development in castle
and white is trying to claim hey your
pawn structure is bad i have more
development than you
so i should be doing well but i think
that black could even consider castling
by hand with bishop e6 king f7
and then bring this rook into the game
queen c6 played instead and
okay black has some dark square
potential issues
but does have the bishop pair
now this looks very pleasant for black i
like it
i like it here what's up to everybody
who's
tuning in i see you trying to do my best
to cover all the action but i'll keep an
eye on the chat to make sure that
everyone's having a good time and this
is a problem
for sergey i think bishop d5 this knight
is now under attack if bishop e7 i'm
going to just take back on e7
and claim my bishop is great and here 96
check i think king e6
what is sergey walking into here what
does he see that i don't because king e6
is such a natural move
applying pressure and not just the
knight but the bishop behind the knight
so knight b7
looks forced i would say otherwise you
know in 94 i just take you
so knight b7 so this was a really bad
transition for sergey but his knight
does extricate itself to the c5 square
so instead we're going to opposite
bishops the bishop goes back to e3 but
is a2 hanging that's the question that
i've been asking myself for a while
at what point can black just say let me
take this pawn because white typically
has b3 to shut that bishop out
and that will be the case here as well
but he goes rook a5 that's way smarter
way way smart just going right for the
a2 pawn not having to worry about the
bishop getting caught there
because the rook will land on a2 instead
and if you play a3 doesn't change much i
just take you on a3
black wins a pawn white still has good
chances to hold by virtue of having the
opposite colored bishops
as is typical in obstacle bishop
positions many of these end games when
liquidation occurs
can still be held but i
think that black is in the driver's seat
for sure
um
let's see okay we'll stay here for a bit
just because i'm curious about
white's counter play and it is circuit
karjakin i mentioned he was on the
outside looking in if he
does very well makes to the knockout and
score some bonus points he could
find himself as a top four finisher in
the sec gp
he can overtake a player like
martirosian
but he needs to prove himself here and
right now not looking so great in this
particular game he is up a little bit on
the clock
but he needs to find his way here and
right now he's spending a lot of time is
he going to play f3 to kick this bishop
is he going to throw his rook into d6 he
plays g4 trying to stop the king from
getting to f5 but that also
makes a bishop f3 and
oh oh that pawn is now a weakness
there's going to be some back rank
issues with checkmating nets so he's
giving himself the
g3 square i'm not sure i'm buying it h5
played if i take you just take with the
bishop that way you don't drop his g7
but wait bishop with eight then there's
rook a7
very important move rook a7 and a whole
what he gives up the pawn just plays
bishop e2
interesting choice there
okay so bishop f3 back does it gives up
the c6 pawn as well
i don't think that circus in any danger
anymore he's definitely not going to win
this game or he should not win this game
i don't want he definitely won't because
crazier things have happened in mutual
time trouble but right now
it's even material he does have to watch
out for allowing another rook on the
last rank he could find himself in a
mating net but
unlikely i think he'll just scoot his
rook back and forth and king h2
can be played now how are you going to
check my name
okay then we're coming to g8 watch out
oh he allows it but king h3 so he made
space
for his king very important you play
rook to g1 now and offer the exchange
of rooks and now the rooks are off okay
this is just
should it be a very very simple draw the
bishop will sacrifice itself they even
agreed to it right here
okay we'll move on we'll move on let's
go back to the beast from leon what is
happening here
how many extra pawns does black have
just one just one it looks like a
million because i see
this phantom length of pawns here and
i guess maximi trace is gonna put a
bishop on a7 the bishop on g1
is overwhelmed h3 can come here here
comes the pawn storm
here comes g4g well not g4 now because
of this pawn but well thank you for
allowing him mcqueen there goes
uh maxime so maxime wins by resignation
let's keep on going a wonderful time
that is malaysian rook end game
okay this pawn is falling immediately
going to be a draw i see he's down the
stretch
in big fish that is vladimir fedo say
evan what the
i've never seen a position just like
this before two bishops
against a bishop and two pawns this
should be a draw because with the bishop
staying on this diagonal
there's no way to force the king into
the corner and deliver a checkmate
nothing like that so this game should
just be drawn
let me look for more games here because
we have
plenty of others still going on here
let's go to
ah no i clicked on the wrong game that
didn't want to check out a game with two
extra queens
nope don't want to check out this game
either the end of the round
this is going to be the situation here
oh king g6
oh missed it okay that's how you misplay
a rook against pawn ending and he had
time to find it
now that's that's sadly inexcusable for
a player
of his caliber so that is a huge missed
opportunity
there in well-known easily winning
position i'm going to take us back
to this moment here where it was winning
how do you play king of g6 first of all
you block the stalemate
because the king wasn't stalemate but
now with the king of the g8 square
you put your king on h6 with check
and after king to h8 the only way to
save the pawn
i slide my rook over to a1 i give you a
check and i
dislodge your king from the defense of
this h7 pawn so i go over here
no longer is a stalemate can come to
jake thank you for this check
and now i win your pawn directly king
and rookie and king of course is a win
and he had another win even after he
missed that opportunity
ah why does it go so far back i don't
want to go all the way back here let's
go back here
so in this position um
right here after king g8 that's a
mistake king g7 was correct
king g6 is played if you queen then
the rook would have went there for
checkmate sad the next round is underway
that's what happens when you're doing a
speed chess tournament i need to
remember that i can't
tell you everything i want to tell you i
am limited for a time so instead of
being so
verbose i need to just get to my point
man so sad so sad
all right let's go to some other games
here let's look at
hmm let's go to this one i'm gonna go to
a new game where
um let's go to nemo's game actually
we'll uh
tune in to nemo i didn't even see that
she was playing but of course we want to
check in to see her tournament seems
like she's struggling out of the gates
but that's what happens in a field like
this she is wearing
her jersey that's pretty cool
i like the color scheme in general i'm a
fan of these light blues
so nemo taking part in this event
always good to see her hopefully she can
score some points and
uh and she's always having a good time
that's the best thing about her streams
no matter her results she's enjoying
herself she's
making sure that everyone's tuned in for
a good one speaking of results
we gotta tune back in for a car
nakamura's stream real quick
because hikaru he's always getting those
results
and he's at a perfect score 3-0 he's
pushing his pawns here as you see
drawing many arrows and highlights oh
gosh
i always learn from watching a card
streams too so it's
good to see him in the form that he's in
today and we
will likely if he maintains the pace
we'll see him in
the knockout but for now we're going to
go to some other games
i have one up here between some great
players
uh we have z kid taking on azeri chest
that is
chakriar mama jarv so
look at these these mutually
nice squares e4 covered by the pawns e5
covered by the pawns
and i think that if either side is going
to play for an edge
here why play c4 which is a somewhat
risky move
just because you're making d4 a little
bit looser um
but you're also obviously putting
pressure on d5 i was going to say
an idea with g4 comes to mind and you
have to be cautious
before pushing pawns in front of your
own king but the center of the board is
really clogged up here and so look at
mamajara put his king on
h8 there could be a rook g8 g5 of his
own and well i don't like that move at
all
i really don't like that move because
you're sort of shutting down
the opportunity to open up the center of
the board
and unless you are quickly getting to
the king side first
i see that black can get there do not
play rook g8 too soon there could be a
knight f7 check
but taking on e4 probably not what
uh was really wanted by
say oh and this knight is trying to get
to d5 perhaps you can also put your rook
on d8 and go right for
this pawn here on d4 now the bishop
should probably move out the way the e6
pawn is hanging
although it's not really hanging because
as soon as the queen takes on e6 the
bishop can take on c5 so
it's sort of fake hanging i do like
black's position here slightly i think
he has a little bit of an edge so
well where to now where to now where do
we go
should we stay here i'm trying to look
for some of these
players where's cassie's fiddler's
game over here let's uh it's going over
to svidler's game why not he's 3-0
he's probably streaming usually is for
these events i see this d6 square and i
get concerned for black's position but
then i
recognize very quickly it's black's turn
because knight d6
actually wouldn't even be that powerful
because bishop could take on f3
but it's an idea to keep an eye on so
knight d6 there's going to be tactics
with knight takes c3
that's why harsha quickly took on d5
the bishop takes back now there's no
knight d6 hitting the bishop on b7
if we trade you fix my pawn structure i
have these kind of hanging pawns but it
looks good
for black in that case you can take on
c4 play knight e5 take on f3 and take on
b2 this is all going to happen
and i like spiller's position he's
grabbing this pawn on b2
and i if i am harsha i'm thinking about
taking this pawn c5 but then i don't
like the consequences of my
double isolated f-pawns that doesn't
look very good so
hey caro won his fourth game i just saw
that out of the corner of my eye
fiddler trying to do the same with the
black pieces what a nice sequence by him
when you have less control when you just
have fewer squares for your pieces
trading often helps you and that's
exactly what further did in this game
and he is going to snag this
can you play f5 f5 is an interesting
move he doesn't do that but
i was looking at f5 as a possibility
there it looked quite interesting
because if you can get your pawns pushed
that also feels quite nice
but he takes the pawn he runs back this
pawn c5 will be
a target here comes rook c6 to win this
poem in c5 so
he will not even be able to keep this
pawn but i wouldn't
be unhappy about what's happened here
for peter i think he actually has
obtained quite a nice position from the
black side no real risk
has safety everywhere in fact it's
white's pawn structure that is worse
because
these are isolated pawns on the queen
side so i could see a future
in this game where white loses
both of these pawns on the queen side
for just one and then has to fend off
a four on three advantage on the king
side but
svidler let's look at his [__] uh
yeah so we'll we'll see
filler is streaming
and um doing very well
so let's move on to another game real
quick we'll come back
later he's going to be at the top of the
standings i believe for
a long time so i want to go to a
wonderful time to
min lay let's go what's going on with
the black pieces here hey
looks pretty nice for him we're about to
see an end game with bishops of opposite
color but look at this pawn on g5
that's the pawn that sticks out most
because this knight on e5 is good
it puts pressure while it defends uh
this pawn over here
i don't know why the arrow went from h
to g6 but this knight is very good
this nana c3 is quite limited and this
bishop can come to e3 and steal the
g-pawn
and that's not a pawn you want to lose
because that becomes an outside passer
for black so take on g5
you just move his bishop somewhere and
then go to g5 g4
and can you really stop that pawn that's
an important question because now bishop
f4
bishop oh gosh of course bishop d4 you
have completely dominated this knight
you will take the knight wherever it
goes and then this g-pawn
runs free nicely done by
wonderful time here really he's just
such an excellent player
but the way he went from that initial
position into this which is pure
domination across the board here and
he's going to try to promote this pawn
g2 91 check thank you for your bishop on
g2 that wins right now
and here he does it it's too good
too good check and there's a piece
so we'll get go away from this game it
looks like uh millie's gonna win
so let's go to this one between whoa
tuning in for
a queen against a pair of rooks but how
many extra pawns do i have
three extra pawns and the king actually
feels quite safe
this is looking really nice here for
white and
lord balrog queen g6 i just pushed the
pawns
so you have to be careful when you do
things like that but it looks like
you're in time because there's no easy
way to stop them
h7 queen g7 is check and i guess of
course the queen g8
helps me promote and that's it king h4
probably also good enough oh wait a sec
wait a sec what do you do about this
pawn
how do you there must be a way here oh
queen g five queen g
check you miss quinn g8 he gets the pawn
no that can't be right because now the
two rooks are doing quite well
no there's no way this is all of a
sudden it's getting bad for white
the rooks actually are better than the
queen with just one pawn so the king is
going to hide he's going to play a6
eventually
he's going to double his rooks in the g
file
uh-uh this is no good this is no good
only can be good for black who's going
to take this pawn at the right time
so he's going to try to improve the
position of his king first but queen c5
check is nice
queen e5 check as possible and that's
good technique by white as well you want
to keep the king as far away from your
pawns as possible so c5 26 check
so that's not going to be played and i
think the king is going to be forced
back into the corner again
and there we see a draw by repetition
the point is that if black
let's say this king over here and you
make some move like c3 i would love to
take it a moment like this
when your king is very far away and my
king perhaps gets here first now there's
still going to be opportunities for
white to draw
but that's black's goal is at the king
here and not back on a8
it's very far away and then there's
gonna be no winning chances for kings
back in the corner
so interesting end game there white
missed
clear win i would say and we do have
just a few games left it looks like
castor is a perfect four four
four let's uh keep on going just down
for the remaining games here
we have crescent moon isn't that grand
master um
trung sun from vietnam if i'm not
mistaken that knight is trapped king g6
does this work
it looks like it works can you seven
king of seven oh stalemate king g6
aren't king here either way stalemate
and we see a draw so the very strong
vietnamese grandmaster cannot pull off
the victory
and well we're heading down the stretch
here final games
looks like dan laz wins his game moves a
three out of four just as we tune in
we have another end game here the knight
should be able to just
wander around but don't watch out for f4
you have to be very careful not to allow
a timely f4 and he plays it now g3 check
it's not where it was needed the king
had to be on h2
in order for this pawn thrust to really
work because now the knight can
sacrifice itself as it just happened
and this is a draw well
without further ado i believe we are
four rounds in the books so we have
um matlakov parham that is
oh my god corbin was like trying to
figure remember his name it's like
gracia
vidit my good friend let's say komski
and many more
at a perfect four or four but we're
gonna head to break
we'll return more from the speed chest
champion grand prix brought to you by
chess.com
patience is not a virtue
it is a weapon
what's your wow rabbit
[Music]
so
and as we return the team is doing a
fair play check our the favorite
process from chess.com is robust and
there is a team of fair play
professionals that use statistical
methods in manual view by top
grandmasters
over 500 million games reviewed in 2020
for fair play i can't count nearly that
i can't count to
500 so that's so many games there
and many confessions from
very highly rated players title players
and it's uh
unfortunate but more than a hundred
thousand closures over the last eight
years so
chess.com is doing everything in its
power to
fend off players who are not competing
fairly
it is really a situation that is closely
monitored
and that's the reason for these breaks
in between
the rounds make sure that everything is
how it should be
and i also want to point out as we look
at the overall leader board in the speed
champion grand prix that one name was
left out thanks to our viewers for
pointing that out
it is dmitry on draken and you'll see
him placed there
behind hike marti roshan and he's a very
good chance
of making his way through if he can
leapfrog hike in the standings because
he has actually switched his username
during the season and i think that
caused some confusion but nevertheless
we do have demetrion draken he is
a superstar i mentioned him earlier as
one of the players to keep an eye on
but i didn't actually realize when i was
saying that that he is a potential
qualifier for the speed
chess championship so you know
well we'll look at dimitri's games he's
such a strong player we see maxine
chagaya
we have maximum vascular grove there so
players are really just trying to make
their way into that fourth qualification
spot
because it does feel like at this point
parham he's got things locked up
nerdy back and artemyev certainly
doesn't he can't be
caught at this point so lots of great
players
fighting for very few uh remaining
places
they will see who ends up qualifying and
i was asked i
saw the chat asking hey can you show a
car's checkmate during the intermission
and oh i didn't even know it i had to
pull it up now for the first time but
that's a checkmate if i've seen one
looks like there's bishop b5
what a lovely move saying please take me
i can also play
my pawn to c6 which is what happened and
the rook went to b6 to say oh i have an
intermezzo you take my queen i take
yours
queen a7 takes and this king is out of
space
that's beautiful that's beautiful stuff
thank you everybody for telling me
informing me about that and our next
round is off let's start with peters
fiddler
we have him streaming here he uh is
playing his game while keeping an eye on
the norway chess game wouldn't be
surprised if peter was actually
commentating on that game
while playing his own and commenting on
that that's just how talented he is
a great respect for peter
and he is doing quite well thus far
in the uh early stages of the
speeches championship grand prix today
but uh we'll
we'll keep an eye on peter as you know
he is
obviously a player that we'd love to see
participating
and right now i have karjakin up the
black pieces i'm going to bring up on
draken's game
as well if he's still in here somewhere
because
we mentioned that he's somebody who's
trying to claw his way
into the speedchest championship and i'm
gonna first
you know keep our eye on karjakin game
explain a little bit then i'll go over
tom draken
so karjakin is up a pawn here this pawn
on c4 is extra let's turn that green
because it's an extra pawn from black
but what white has a compensation for
that pawn is a great center let's
get rid of that and flexibility and the
bishop on b7 doesn't look so good
the pieces for black at the moment
aren't optimally placed
but if you can trace some of these off
maybe play c5 at the right moment
without dropping b5
if you start trading pieces off black
does have this extra pawn so white is
trying to put pressure
if you take on e5 take back with a pawn
gain some space for my knight on e4
but that's why black is just refraining
from the time being
and it does feel like c5 now can be
played and if c5
is safely played black is just so much
better
uh with the extra pawn but there goes
the uh the sirens there goes the
ambulance and
maybe it's for my evaluation the
position because i did just see after
rook a to d8
the evaluation bar off to the side says
no not so fast white is actually doing
okay here
even though i tend to like black's
chances in such a position g4 will not
help because if c5 does indeed happen
you're making your own king weaker
kayaking plays it let's move on to our
guy dimitri on draken we're gonna move
on there
so let's see on draken is the white
pieces against the i can't even call him
a feeding master alexis sorokin
is like 25 40 classical feed it
the guy is grand master in everything
but title but yet he has an fm title so
it's the
kramnik kramnik was an fm rated like
and um sorokin
doesn't have the title but he certainly
has the rating and this position is an
exchange up for black
and it's a clear exchange not even a
pawn for that exchange but watch out for
the king look at these dark squares
in front of and next to this black king
bishop c3
queen to d4 queen e5 and go in for
checkmate that's
obviously a main idea here now black
isn't going to allow that
so if queen e5 queen f6 that's the point
let me just
keep offering this trade i'll go back
you go back like we'll just go back and
forth and
try to make a draw here white is better
and he plays queen e5 so queen f6 has to
be played because there's a mate on h8
he's gonna go back to e3 you're not
trading queens here you can play queen
to
c7 but then watch out for rook c8 so
queen 27 does not work rook c8 is a nice
move
just offering up your exchange in return
and getting the
open c file so zip queen to d6 now he
didn't play this immediately he could
have
and one of the issues is a timely bishop
c4 bishop e5 like a d6 check trying to
open up an attack on this king
and the queen is a bad block hitting
piece another issue is queen h6 comes
at some moment and your queen is on f7
where it defends
your king of course you can put your
rook on f7 to defend some of these
squares so here
queen d4 but then there's e5
now that is i have to show this on the
board queen d4
e5 you take on poisson i take your queen
when you take the queen back you lose
the bishop at the end of this so e5 is a
really really nice move
that would shut down the diagonal and
give black a huge advantage
so bishop e5 played first this bishop
can drop back to b3
but when it drops to b3 this bishop can
come to c2
to offer an exchange of bishops i do not
like the way this is going for on draken
a queen b6 there could be queen h6 but
then there's rook f7
so okay bishop d4 played queen back to
d6 i imagine
and we may very well see an attempt to
draw a bishop c2 what's wrong with that
that's something i'm still looking at
offering a trade of bishops in fact
forcing
a trade of bishops that one can not move
anywhere
besides taking on c2 and i'm starting to
like black's position more and more not
that objectively it's that much better
but you see how this game is going the
trajectory of the game it went from
potential attack for white to now white
just trying to
stave off the swapping of pieces
because that will only favor black so i
think that and draken
he needs to figure this out quickly and
he doesn't really want to make a draw
but perhaps it draws his best bet so
maybe he'll continue bishop d4 bishop e5
and say
all right alexi you play well you fended
me off here
i got nothing
and still no move is bishop d4
a draw but no it would not be a force
draw so
i was wondering if like he's about to
make the draw and that's why he's
thinking by the way peters fiddler did
win his game so congrats to him he
continues to
ascend the in the standings
all right so bishop d4 played at long
last queen came back to d6
of course protecting e7 keeping e6 check
off the table
yeah i think we're gonna queen d7 look
at black playing on now
i think it's very smart d6 check bishop
takes queen takes here it comes
and then black will play e6 in the end
of this line
and the good news is this bishop is
incredible on e5 but actually rook f7
very nice move if you played e6 that
would have
given white a protected pass pawn and
white would have played f4 with a pawn
on d6
so this is an improvement for black
who's going to put the king on h7
and now g7 and h8 are under control so
sorokin playing well
his king still has to be cared for
and if that's the case it's not going to
be so easy to win this position
but here he comes queen c5 this piece to
come out watch out for maybe a rook at
fade at some moment
like right now bishop d4 there's queen
c4 or queen f5
queen c4 does pin this bishop and and
attacks a2 just you can take this a2
pawn
there's no threats here these squares
are under black's control not white so
he's trying to do a queen g5 queen h6
that's clear
by putting the bishop on e3
and look at the queen swing right over
to f5 nicely done very nicely done
here come the pieces you in fact don't
even have the attack that you once
thought you might because you're doing
the bishop on a1 and
making use of the diagonals so black has
done a great job of coordinating his
pieces
he's now opening exchange and upon this
could be it for on draken's chances
perhaps if he
doesn't make it to the knockout he will
have to win all the rest of his games to
have a chance usually it's eight and a
half points
that makes the knockout if you lose this
one really rough start for him
i always have to start the middle of the
tournament at this point
and hikaru did win his game i see that
it looks like mama jarv won his game
karjakin won
so just keeping an eye on some of those
results there as we see komski in first
place
and tai is well did it we're gonna have
to look at vin's game next round i think
so there's no attack here is queen rook
d6
one move threat the queen dropped back
can i just push the spawn why not the
rook covers the d7 square
and rook c1 doesn't work queen f5 that
just
ices the game trade the queens here it
is game over
queen c2 funny move it's like a
resignation
so that was a nicely played game by
sorokin he beats on draken
let's go back to min why not he has a
chance squad oh but this is not good for
him
it's two knights against a rook and a
pawn now just by
material that should be okay for black
but not in this endgame when this pawn
is hard to
stop over here and there are two of them
look at this king h3 is a threat because
this knight is under attack
so the knights are needed protecting one
another and they can't actually move
because if you move the g5 knight you
lose e4
movie 4 you lose g5 oh gosh giving up
this ground is no good h3
takes this
and rook c2 check and then rook c8 our
rxc1 is better maybe and then
push to spawn so win and wonderful time
is going down to this one
king c2 okay you would have won the game
qc3
not bringing the king in all right it
doesn't matter too much because it's
completely winning position
but uh maybe not the most accurate
technique and
i mean it does resign the game so we
have a few more games to see parham is
playing oh
two knights against a rook but this is
different because it's two knights
pure for a rook and the king should go
back to g2 i don't know why it's
running where it is and you need to get
your king to f3 but king g5
knight check oh but there will be rook
rook f2 with here kh4 so knight 3 king
h4
and knight f4 those rook takes f2 so
we'll check here
and if you take this pawn does chess.com
make this an immediate draw
oh i actually okay king takes h3 would
have been played so it would have been
immediate draw
but this is technically a drawn position
there's no way to win except for a help
checkmate
but i would have liked to see it been
played out because it's not always so
easy
but okay here also king takes h3 would
have uh
resulted in a draw okay timo feyev just
pushing the pawns we saw at mexican
version of
in a similar position earlier in the
event with
a phalanx of pawns on the king side
where his opponent tried to promote
pawns of zone
this bishop is doing a great job of
blockading and hear f2 bishop takes h2
thank you for this queen on h1
and timofev wins the game i think our
viewers may not be so familiar with
timofeo but he
is an exceptionally strong grandmaster
and
doing very well now with four and a half
points out of five games
one game remaining chess player 99 19
taking on moscolenko and this looks like
a complete and utter draw
there really is very little to think
about at this point just move your king
with your rook
don't get checkmated not too difficult
to accomplish
so
so that was a draw
all right so we're getting next round
here with hikaru taking on
uh groucho let's uh stay i would say
we're going to look at vidic's game
guess the car was 5-0 we still do expect
him
to make his way all the way through
and let's uh look at vidit because we
haven't seen him this game
once and he usually is streaming over
there on
youtube and he is the black pieces
against
amin tabatabai and what's always funny
to me is because video just started this
account and he's playing while streaming
his rating is 28.57
he is underrated grossly underrated on
this account i think his rating is
somewhere
in the ballpark of 29.50 usually or
above 2900 that's for sure but he's
taking on a very strong player from iran
and right now we see this carlsbad set
up with pawns from b7
to d5 here you
sometimes would like to push this pawn
up from b2 to b5
use a pawn minority attack and why is it
called that
black has three pawns here and white has
just two and
you're the one who's trying to crash
through because you have an
open line for your rook so so far very
normal position do not move this knight
away from f6 because you drop the d5
pawn
as the pawn c6 pin to the queen so
knight e4 would be a big blunder because
of knight takes d5
so just keep that in the back of your
minds so 95 is sometimes possible here
if you take i take with the pawn
and then i have knight takes d5 so did
it
preemptively protects this pawn of the
time dropping his bishop back and that
means that if 95 i can take
because now white is the one who can't
take with the pawn e5
because there's d4 so just show that
very quickly that i put the bishop on e6
to open up a line of attack
on the queen and then attack his knight
on c3
so queen c2 is dropped back first so if
you do want to take with the d pawn
had to move the queen away and what's
going on here e4 at some point can be
considered
for white it leaves you with an isolated
pawn so
not always mentally that easy to play
but it is a standard idea now i wouldn't
be so sure because black is ready
to challenge on the open line and there
may be a way to play bishop d3 move the
knight away from after play f3 yourself
and pushed upon e4 so he does trade off
this knight from e4
and i guess white is claiming semi open
c
file black can't really initiate any
pawn breaks
he's not that i see so he should be
slightly better nothing major here
though
okay let's uh move on from this game
we've been here for
a large farther now let's go back to
that hikaru nakamura game because i just
saw
an inter mezzo being played f7 check
by hikaru so he could have taken his
queen back right away
but he probably didn't want to allow
this pawn to take on f6 so by playing f7
check
you keep this pawn stuck in its place
and then you take back on g3
next move and that's quite important
because this knight would like to go the
e4 square but if there are pawn on f6
that could
potentially go to f5 that's a nice way
to challenge not to mention the pawn f6
covers
a squarely e5 look at this knight going
right into e5 pawn to f4
i think that car made a very smart
decision here here comes c3
open up the c line for this rook and the
c line
something i said c lion so trying to
maneuver the pieces and just at every
advantage
possible in the position so c3 trying to
open up this rook
the problem is hey maybe the b3 pawn is
an issue c4 now is possible it forces on
poisson
otherwise you lose the e6 bond but we're
going to trade this rook is going to
have to come to e3 i believe to protect
the pawn on b3
but this pawn and this pawn are problem
pieces for black
so rook c5 bishop b3 knight b3 rook to
b3
this is all going out may work to be one
first
is necessary because rook b1 you can't
play bishop d5 because i'll take on b7
and at the end of this i'll have a check
on the seventh rank so if rook b1 forces
either rook to b or rook to d7 rook d7
doesn't work because knight f3
comes into e5 with a fork on this rook
and this king
so i know i'm thinking very tactically
here but after rook to b1
there's rook to b8 and then i can trade
everything on b3 and take on a5 instead
he goes
this way and there may be a check here
comes rick to c6
pinning this pawn once the king comes up
to f6
the rook can only go to e8 to defend the
pawn and then this rook can come to a6
to win the pawn a5 so it is a very
interesting sequence by hikaru but maybe
rook to b4 is possible giving up the e
pawn
to win white's a pawn he does not do
that instead
as i was saying protect c6 gives up a5
this is an extra pawn in an end game
for hikaru very good winning chances
because this pawn e6 is an isolated pawn
that will require
some serious defense from black
so i'm liking the look of hikaru's
position definitely liking his chances
here
and this is
going to be a very difficult defensive
task for a boar scratch chef if he's
even able to
hold it so we'll come back here in a
moment
i'm just trying to look and find as many
games as possible we'll go to peter's
fiddler's game really quickly i'll come
back to the cars game
of course you can watch these players as
they're streaming on their own channels
i just saw a pawn
f5 move and i don't know who this is
but i see a grand master from spain so i
could check it out in a bit but there is
a pin on the g pawn which is why the
bishop is
immune from capture but black's pieces
also are coming really into the game
nicely here
bishop d2 i could see a rook d h being
nice there's no attack against black's
king
you have a semi-open file but you also
have an isolated pawn on e5
and black has isolated pawns of his own
a6 and c5
but i like the way that black's pieces
are coordinating here
and there's a pin down the d file the
bishop can't move the rook is
hanging behind it could be a tough
position
for white going forward c4 is
check but you have to be careful about
your king over here so c4
he plays it and after key
okay play c3 that's the move i'm looking
at because queen takes c3 i can finally
take your bishop
i don't know if it works it actually may
walk into some kind of
checkmate or maybe uh just a bunch of
checks
that i can't get out of but c3 the
bishop can't capture because
there's a pin so it said bishop e8 very
safe and sound move
bishop g4 so that way
the bishop protects the rook all right
this game is and you can just win a pawn
maybe put the bishop on f7 and say
thank you for the material looks right
to me
just take on e6 you can play f5 but then
bishop f5
i'm trying to take advantage of this
rook not being defended there
so he plays queen d4 he's going right
for please move your bishop
can i take it queen d1 okay piss queen
e4 he's
smarter than i am sacrificing pieces
that don't belong to me as is typical
but i still like black's position
because black's king for the time being
looks safer these bishops are
in a great spot here and white does feel
a little bit tied down and we're only
seven seconds left and even notice that
queen e3 watch out for b3 okay we can
trade queens
but if we trade queens there's no way to
win this game anymore
unless this king somehow runs that
quickly
no it's a draw okay let's go back to the
cars game
he's trying to i'm just trying he's
winning this end game he's up
three pawns now so he car stole the
eight pawn
and stole the rest and a6 and then push
some of these all of them can go forward
too many extra pawns three many extra
balls actually
so we gave up the a pawn but he didn't
take it and now
f5 can come to g5
no good yeah just resignation
resigns let us look at kayaking's game
against uh
harsha we've seen harsher play before in
this event
wait can you play b2 he's gonna sack his
queen for the rook and then played b2
oh that looks scary but somehow this
queen covers everything
wait this isn't hanging oh my gosh
sergey you could have queen and
protected the pawn but you have no time
in your clock
so if white plays for a win he might
lose so he's playing for the draw
okay sergey no buddy
right here look at this he's trying to
play rook c6 because he saw
queen f5 coming but b1 equals queen
actually defends this pawn
and he had no time on his clock i get it
it's very hard to play with two seconds
but queen promotion that actually also
defends and black should be winning next
movie you can play rook to g8
so that's a sad miss opportunity for
sergey he's still doing very well
plenty of time left in this tournament
he will need to continue
whoa i'm like confused black is down in
exchange
white should be kind of crushing here
but how do you make progress you need to
kick this knight out and go for the f7
pawn
okay well rook takes up seven is just a
free pawn so the knight kicked itself
out
and oh let's check mate let's check me
um well the rook
and the knight and the queen
and these pieces are sad over here
[Music]
yikes okay let's see if there any more
games yet left excuse me
we have a couple oh queen and bishop
versus queen
should be an easy hold just trade queens
that's it
and is that the last game of that round
oh we have one more
okay now we have hikaru taking on alex
sure
1981 don't know that is but let's uh
let's start a new cars game
cars 6 out of 6 deserves our our
attention here
obviously brilliant player great
streamer and
perfect score in this scc gp so a
quieter opening setup thus far or is you
can play f4 though that's the question
because if white plays f4
it goes from quiet to potentially quite
chaotic
and wouldn't be surprised if white plays
some kind of bishop e3 it's the
move that players who are worried about
potentially losing to a car we played
knight a4
okay similar like length that quiet move
to attack your bishop try to get the
bishop pair
i like the decision honestly i think
it's a good call
so let's see
so trades gets the bishop pair you can
play f4 if you want you can also just
play
quieter black can play knight a5 at some
point so you
may want to keep an eye on his bishop so
after knight a5 now there's check
bishop a4 bishop c2 you slide the back
bishop back into c2 so you keep the
bishop pair
and i wouldn't be surprised if white
plays bishop b5 here trying to keep the
bishop pair and now play d4 with the
idea of
d5 so why is the bishop pair important
when you have the dynamic of a knight
against a bishop and you only have one
bishop
the color complex that is not the color
of your bishop
can be quite exciting it can become
quite vulnerable so if you trade your
light square bishops
then the light squares can be useful for
the black knights because this bishop on
c1 can't actually help you
fend off the light squares so that's one
of the reasons why you often see players
keep
both bishops when you start with the two
bishops advantage instead of just
trading off
the a pair of bishops so f5 by a car
that was the benefit of putting the
bishop on e6 you took away
this pin from c4 to g8 and now here
comes f5
black's position is better in my eyes
everything is safe and sound no
weaknesses
d4 is met by politics e4 how the d5s
were covered
and f3 i mean f3 is not exactly
a move that gives you much confidence
whereas d5 certainly
does there is a nice three pawns
in a row on the fifth rank and what is
what are these pawns doing on d3 and f3
they're more
passive pawns defending the e4 square
whereas black is the one applying
pressure immediately in the position
so i definitely like hikaru's position
here
the pawn a2 can also be a target at some
point watch out for queen c5 check
and that's why he takes on c6 do you
take with the pawn or the knight
that's the question and
not an easy one to answer because if you
take with the pawn you reinforce your
center
and if you take it upon the black
snipe can be captured if that's what
white was looking for i don't think you
really want to do that but you may have
to because black is going knight g6 and
i play f4 your bishop gets trapped over
here
so you don't want to strain the bishop
either
and car's position looks excellent his
time management looks excellent watch
out for f4 i've been talking about this
move
and it's important to note that this c6
pawn defends d5 so if you take on d5
i just replace my pawn with another pawn
oh gosh
look at these pawns here it's not
letting me highlight that one there we
go
four on the fifth ring
okay c4 c4 which am i do i
push it do i take somewhere
now it's a difficult moment because i
still like black's position i'm just not
entirely sure how to
continue from this point forward i think
d4
looks reasonable
i don't really want to capture i'd say
can i capture it this way
probably fe4 it plays d4
first that's as i was mentioning the
first one that came out i'm looking at
b5 and c4 by the way
and he plays f4 just to gain space now
g7 and g5 push these pawns
could be an idea knight to h4 could be
an idea but i'm looking at b5 takes in
c4 not anymore
because after b5 takes c4 there's bishop
b4 and that's a problem
but my essential point was if you took
on c4 i'd have d3 so just trying to
advance my pawns forward here but it
doesn't work out
so the position remains closed here
comes
g5 if you take with a bishop now there's
c5 saying hey
you have one move attack i'm blocking
that good for you
and this rook coming f6 will be extra
powerful defending
the pawn on b6 while helping to play g5
g4
right you put the rook rook f6 for g6
and play g4
push forward here this is just a great
position for black who has
so much more space and
okay g4 played if you take how is white
going to take back
because it does open up the f-file and
the rook on f8 barrels right down with
this pawn
f3 so that's a risky decision but is
someone that is somewhat standard and
look at a car that is how strong he is
he says you know what to heck with the
king side
i'm going over here on the queen side
and i have an extra pawn
from the b through the h-file it's seven
on seven in terms of number of pawns
but black has an extra pawn because this
a3 pawn
is off on the side and is cemented in
place so look at him go he's trying to
take
on c4 and that will free up his d4
pawn and we'll see just a trade here
okay
after the trade on c4 you can take on g5
takes you to the pawn i would probably
think with the queen on
c4 because with the queens on the board
this pawn is more of a target it feels
like and just
there's a potential issue with more
places and here comes rook to b3 this
just looks bad no matter what honestly
yeah rook b3
you can take on a4 too if you want to
ruby 3 is obviously smart
watch out f3 is hanging a4 is hanging c4
is under pressure
d3 actually was a possible move because
i had to go to c3 and then c4 drops but
now d3 there's knight to
g1 may rook to b8 to get your rook to b2
rook to e3 as possible everything is
possible
sounds like a nice hallmark card but i
mean
just black position is completely
dominant
so
okay trades c4 is hanging and then e2 is
hanging as well
a4 is still hanging d3 is possible and
then queen d4 check for instance
queen a6 just saying your queen gets no
squares
and here come oh c4 i didn't want to
play c4 interesting
i guess c4 would like queen b4 or
something like that but i'm looking at
these c4 type of moves and just
pushing the pawns forward
so card down to 20 seconds going down to
10 could be a bit of a time scramble he
does play c4
queen e6 keeping the knight protected
keeping the palm protector c3 looks good
knight c6 probably wins this pawn
directly
and by probably it does
okay so not that much time though akara
needs to be careful
so does his opponent of course but i'm
saying it from a car's point of view
because
he has a much better position so bishop
b7 look at that trading the queens off
that's trade queens i have an extra pawn
and my pawns are doing really well over
here
knight on g6 protecting e5 protecting e7
queen c4 would have traded queens
bunsen goes queen a6 bishop v5 uh oh
that's it
that's all you need that's a pin and a
win and a
win on the clock as well so a car wins
the game let's
go over to uh min oh
he's in trouble too weak too slow is
neither too weak nor too slow at this
point
yeah min is just midnight's done for
there
and uh okay
so let's see if there any more games
ringing up plenty what am i
even need to ask the question a mean
type of value down a pawn here but
should defend this end game the rook is
perfectly placed the king king has come
to d8
and if king d6 there's rook to d2 check
keeping the king away
so now you just give a bunch of checks
put the king in front of the pawn give a
bunch of checks rook d2 roxy 2 rook b2
etc
and this is just a draw what you would
need for white is to put this pawn back
on c5 and bring your king to c6 but
not possible game is a draw
let's keep on going okay we have
matthias blue bomb with the black pieces
as queen f5 dropping the c6 pawn but
giving the
oh actually is it perpetual can i win
the c3 pawn
i feel like black can try to play on
here
well now bishop b4 is super solid
i was going to take on c3 though and try
to push the c pawn that looked a little
more likely but black is actually down
opponent even realized that
i was so focused on the center of the
board that i didn't realize that black
is the one
who to some extent needs to be careful
bishop f8 there's bishop g6 okay
bishop back to b4 yeah if the queens
come off it's immediately a draw
wait bishop hate bishop hate oh my gosh
big blunder here queen h6
check there's no mate i want to play g4
but that's pin so i can't get away with
that bishop d6 or queen f4 check it's
only a check kingdom's e6
and there are opportunities even down
two pawns if the queens get traded
okay 26 queen d7 queen h7 that's not
winning the queen
okay that's pawn on c3 uh-oh
bishop v6 bishop e7 you can you could
have brought his bishop down that way
to win the f-bomb so white is in
business here
some blunders by blue bound
but even if the queens get traded oh
queen e7 check check and win this pawn
oh no no no no no that's what i was
talking about if you trade the queens
there's going to be very good chances to
hold this
oh maybe it doesn't look so horrible
anymore well
trade that's important keeping those
pawns on the board
felt important but maybe just push the
g6 and push the bishop here
yeah the presence of these pawns not
good qg5 h6
h7 bishop v5
yikes and blue bomb goes down
brolic is a happy camper here
87 mate thank you very much and that is
checkmate
so let's see any more games going on yes
indeed
no one no that one's not going on just
kidding clicking on a game that i
thought was going on but
in fact it was over so with that
seven rounds are in the books hikaru and
clear first
followed by parham amin zubaii that is
shakira mamjarov
and a whole host of players there with
the six out of seven we're gonna take
another fair play break and when we
return we'll have the final three rounds
the swiss
as we get ready for the knockout portion
of the speeches championship grand prix
brought to you by chess.com
patience is not a virtue
[Music]
it is a weapon
what's your wow rabbit
[Music]
and during these breaks while players
take a little bit of rest
you know stretch their wrists from
moving at the speed of light
the fair play team is practicing the
event
as you can see here there are 17
full-time team members
including five statisticians seven chief
detectives and five title player manual
review experts
and the checks are happening in real
time dedicated proctors
everybody is trained so it's uh it's
really good
to help prevent cheating or to make sure
that
people who do so do not get away with it
but right now
we know that hikaru nakamura he is at
seven out of seven the only
completely perfect score we have three
players who have dropped just a half
point parham maksoudlu
amin tabithabayi and shakira mamjarov
and then we have many players
sitting with six out of seven points
including
nerdy back abductor if he's in eighth
place the chess warrior but without
further ado we have a liftoff i see the
games are
underway let's start with karjakin i
know i've
tuned in quite a bunch to his game so
it's because he's on the outside looking
in
if we talk about the overall leaderboard
for the sec gp
he needs to make it to the knockout and
maybe even win the knockout
to qualify automatically for the
speeches championship
so here he goes with the black pieces
playing the
azeri grimmaster vulgar rasulov nothing
too special just yet
by the way hikaru is taking on parham
and he carved with the white pieces he
takes
the approach that he played and gets
magnus many times
with this capturing on c6 a delayed
exchange
spanish and look at the e4 square that's
one for white's pieces
and that's what he's going to claim is
his advantage if you can put his knight
on e4 for example
and then even go g4 g5 that knight not
only blockades
some of the squares here it can help you
launch an attack on this square like f6
but the d5 square is
available to blacks knight as well so
parham's position
so far it's a tale of these
central light squares and part goes
knight c8 to go knight to d6
and then trade off the knight on e4 so
that's actually quite a
safe approach by parham here knight d6
next
let me trade off your wonderfully placed
p74 and that's that
so let's uh keep on looking down the
list of players we have
amin tabai taking on shakira mama jarv
nothing too special just yet standard
opening position the bishop on h2 is
currently blocked by this pawn on e5 but
if that pawn ever pushes to e4 the
bishop gets a new lease on life in this
position so bishop f5 played
hitting the queen saying do go e4 try
that
because it frees up a square like d4
later for my knight to reroute into the
game
excuse me so we saw a swap on d3
white is first to the d file but it
doesn't really amount to all that much
because where are the weak points in
order to use an open line
or to try to claim an advantage you need
to
start attacking things but what are you
going to attack e5 is safe and sound
these pawns on the queen side perfectly
okay there's nothing major going on
to my eyes an h5 gives the king some
space it's not really going for an
attack it's more about giving the king
some space so if a piece ever lands on
the eighth rank
it's not going to result in some awkward
tie ups so let's keep on going we have
um
many games of course still in action
here let's go to vidit's game video
guzrati
he is taking on the chess warrior that's
nerdy becca mustard off
and wait knight b5 is the threat
what knight b5 is or knights d4 okay
maybe there's knight to z4 but i've just
said knight b5
and now i have to really calculate here
knight b5
knight takes d4 and what is happening
there so let's let's try this knight b5
takes and oh my gosh i can
take here first that looks really smart
because now everything's under attack
we're gonna go to the live board
see if it happens he played knight b5
step one complete but
knight d4 rook takes c7 the both queens
are under attack and i understand what
black's idea was if knight d4
and you take on d6 i take on c1 with
check first
and here it comes rook takes c7
shouldn't win i mean
i'm looking at this position trying to
figure out all the tactics here but rook
c7
if you take my queen i take your rook
with check here it comes
here comes in vidic gujrathi looks like
he's going to go to
seven out of eight with this game
so right now white is up a rook for just
a pawn
and if i take on e2 for example
then this queen is under attack and
white's queen is not
so after 92 the king just hop over the
corner or play king f1 one of those
moves would be good
so he plays knight 62 check is out of
desperation because he realized he made
a mistake
and i both moves look totally fine but
king h1 feels a bit safer
to me and this queen is under attack
this rook is under attack so the bishop
can't even take on b5 because you lose
this rook back here
with check and not just check but uh
likely a background checkmate
wow what a sequence here
and he plays king f1 going after this
i think knight g3 check is possible
that's why i was saying not to play king
f1 knight g3 if you take on g3 bishop b5
now is
check to the king and then i pick up
your rook after that i know that's a lot
to calculate there
so many pieces flying into position but
the point is bishop b5
would be check if not for the knight so
now bishop b5 was the threat
the king came all the way to e1 and if
this works it's just winning
but i didn't really want to bring the
king all the way out to
e1 here queen b6 so take
and then you just take this and now you
have a full rook
so vida guzrati is up a full rook in
this position
barring some kind of absolutely crazy
blunder you should just be
taking this one home queen a5 is just
one check
you can start running your king back
over to the king side
and that's that nicely done
by vida gujarati here so let's uh move
on from this one let's go to hikaru's
game against parham
because it's akaru and whoa okay
so that's one check and you can pick up
b7 but he didn't want to go because rook
to b at the end of that
f2 look at this pawn here that's a
really strong pawn protected by a piece
d4 is a possibility but black has c5
to try to get after that oh gosh
rookie eight okay and is there some kind
of
just see i mean white's king is not
exactly
that happy over here and if you take and
the bishop takes well protected here
so this pawn
really strong if you take with the pawn
d4 there'll be a queen c4 check
so it's starting to look like a problem
for hikaru so
d3 comes to mind not sure it works but
d3 check is something that comes to mind
d takes c3 of course is also looking
quite
interesting because the queen is needed
to defend this bishop
so after d takes e3 you can't take with
the queen on uh
see there's a d3 check was played rook
takes can't take with the queen stick
with the king
because this bishop wait what gives it
the bishop
he's trying to get some kind of queen d7
check so he realized the position was
losing
regardless so he's going for some sort
of attack he is
up two seconds and in a mutual time
scramble anything can happen but black
is up a piece for just one queen to
check
oh okay well queen e4 is even better
wins the rook nice by parham
and hikaru is going to lose this game
he's still in great shape seven out of
eight
but not a game he wanted to lose of
course and very stubborn
defense turned into offense for parham
because
well back way back here
the queen aaa check was probably what he
carrier wanted to play
but after king d7 queen take a b7 rook
to b8 you have to watch out
because b2 is falling and that's
obviously not what you're looking for
let's go back to karjakin
with the black pieces completely winning
here
he is up no material actually wow i
thought he was up the pawn
but i saw the past pawn potential with
the spawn trying to come c3
so he's gonna take on a4 don't allow
bishop to c6
that's checkmate so you need to stop
that and play rook to d6 good move
and now you can come to b4 there's no
more checkmate so you're just winning
the game
so you gotta just watch out for one turn
king b5 he's gonna rook b6 next
i think so but if you trade there's
always knight to d6 at the end
and here come the pawns here come the
pawns knight d6 hitting the rook
protecting
protecting everything this knight is
just an octopus knight
and after bc3 is king c5 and then b2
kraken wins moves to seven of eight so
he may even face
hikaru nakamura in the next game it's a
possibility
so we have lord balrog taking on borscht
uh that is matlikov and i think
lord balrog is kusadinov so i'm not
mistaken
and well this is going to be a win for
wait a sec this could be two nights
against the king which would be a draw
so what white should do oh
terrible move he pre-moved it it was a
horrible move
oh my gosh that stinks from him oh but
now he's going to win he kicked the
bishop away
oh he's going to win anyway what just
happened
what'd he do matlikov you
you're gifted a piece
oh a vey just like here
knight f7 the idea was if the bishop
stayed here let's say the king went here
knight f7 is good because you played g6
g7 jade and queen
but he pre-moved knight f7 which is a
horrible blunder
and after king takes knight e5 you just
have to be careful not to allow this
pawn to get to g6
so here king g4 check
i mean sorry check here king e4 is the
wrong way it's keep your king
attach the pawn because if knight to g7
you have this
bishop f7 it's very important that you
keep your king as close to the pawn as
possible
really difficult to see in time trouble
but the essential point is that you want
to be able to sacrifice your bishop for
the pawn
in some manner it doesn't have to be
directly it doesn't have to be bishop
captures pawn
it just means that when your bishop is
lost you also steal that final pawn so
that was the way to do it
and that's a missed opportunity by
matlikov let's go to the final few games
that we have here we have mazdovich that
is sebastian mazet
and while knight e1 f3 check is just
winning i have to check mate don't even
take the rook in the corner okay he took
it
didn't need to and he's winning
with black
let's make 23. gigi
all right so we're let me look at the
standings i haven't
paid attention too much parham and mama
jarvis seven up to eight
hikaru karjakin i'm not sure who alex
sur is but once i know i'll let you know
uh that's komski
we have um ivan panzulaya
and because dino kuzovov did it
some great players up there okay i
wouldn't be surprised if this game
doesn't draw very quickly
you know how i feel about quick draws
but i imagine a draw will be offered
relatively soon let's see
how many movies do you think four
okay we already have to move three
oh no draw well we might get a game
so we actually are getting a game we're
getting some
mainline spanish where
you think oh i want to take on b3 but
black almost never does
because that helps white finish off some
development here
oh who knew i knew and that's a draw it
was
ten moves so excuse me for saying four
moves
but i knew that the draw would happen
because obviously let's go to hikaru
against vidit
and car puts up on f3 which opens this
bishop up and
does not allow white to castle so
i'm not sure i love this from hikaru's
point of view right now
he plays f4 okay so a knight can come to
g4
trying to get to f2 that looks quite
annoying
in fact it looks extremely annoying what
do you do after knight to g4
i'm like h6 after it
not sure i'm buying this
knight g4 okay
f takes e5 is possible i used to play
the vienna as white so i know that
sometimes you can take on e5 and get
your queen out
and try to like deliver a checkmate
against black but
didn't like this is the position because
queenie too quickly
so bishop f4 now you can throw in bishop
f2 check if you want that's something
that's
a nuisance but now bishop f2 the king
can come to d2
instead of having to oh that's a double
attack
and the bishop has to stay protecting
this knight as well wait a sec
this is kind iffy territory right now
to be very very careful in this position
can't castle right you can't guess up
through check
if you play rook f1 there may even be
knight takes h2 and the point of knight
h2 is after bishop h2 i take your knight
on g5
this doesn't look very good of course
after work f1
b2 is also hanging that's
not out of the question but i didn't
like after
queen b2 there's knight takes f7 so you
have to be careful about that
as the king would have to walk into the
line of the rook
so knight takes h2 does hit this rook
i think that's just a good move
although there could be some kind of e5
type of movie to keep an eye out on
not as easy as i'm making it sound but
knight takes h2
looks very very possible here knight h2
e5 queen f5 keep the queen attached to
that knight on g5
i think that it will find it
there he goes knight takes h2 and this
is dangerous territory for
hikaru because he cannot afford to lose
this game if he wants to make it to the
knockout stage same with
it eight and a half points is the
qualification number
and as you see that parham and mama jar
are both eight out of nine of their
quick draw
so eight and a half points that's what
you need so losing this game would
likely kick either player out of the
knockout
and you see a car sitting and thinking
now realizing oh this is a problem for
me
because my bishop is overloaded
defending h2 and defending g5
and then black has the bishop here to
boot
so what to do here i think you probably
have to take on h2
and bring the bishop back to f4 he does
that queen h4 g3
so you can reinforce the bishop here
queen g4
looks pretty good you are a pawn but
actually this stops by excuse me white
from castling
because if you castle bishop g4 lands on
the board and you lose in exchange
bishop e3 queen e3 queen g2 not
recommended
that's exactly the type of transition
that white would want
castle coins it's still not possible
because of bishop g4 that's
a big nuisance
so a car still can't castle he can take
on b6 but then a takes b6
and you're opening the a file knight c5
played
okay i like that move it's reasonable i
think you can
okay just castles right away still can't
castle queen side for
white because of bishop g4 okay
that move did not come recommended
bishop g4
still looks fine if white can't castle
it's not going to be so fun
it takes in c5 first plays a6 so vivid
playing
the solid approach but now castle and
queen side still can't be played
because bishop g4 so unfortunately for a
car
not able to castle buddy plus queen f2 i
would look out for the a7 square from
did it
that bishop can move to say e7 and then
queen a7
that could be a problem so
in fact after bishop e7 he doesn't
diego's king d2
his king is just going to castle by hand
after rookie team e1
here comes rk1 and honestly voice
position is not so bad it's an extra
pawn for black but
obstacle bishops for the long term it
means that reduced winning chances
so who else is in the running here we
have many people looks like
oh we have another player joining at
eight out of nine
so i think there's gonna be a bunch of
people at the top let's go to the game
between
com actually there's king on c3 but i'm
going to go to the game between cops and
kayaking real quick
just see what's happening here as both
players have seven and eight
kamsky with the white pieces he's up a
pawn
and this pawn is probably going to be
lost in the future
so komski in great shape to take down
karjakin
it's a good show of this here this pawn
on a
and c4 permanently weak and he offers a
trade so that when he takes an eight his
bishop comes right back to d5 and he
wins c4 so he has
gone up two pawns in the ensuing ending
whether or not it's easy to win that
remains to be seen but it looks
like a winning position you take the
pawn you move the king up start marching
your pawns
put all these pawns and light squares
should be winning
just don't be left with only the h pawn
look at the corner
look at the bishop corner don't match so
you would not want to trade f pawns
kamsey's not going to do that let's go
back to the car against video game
um oh by the way komsky actually won my
resignation as soon as i turned away
bishop d4 queen a7
okay if it has to be very careful here
but it's rook d6 mission d4
so the king is trying to run away 25
check queen e5
means that he'll he can't be worse as he
is up a pawn
and what's happening here so can't get
g5 h4
in this bishop can always park on g5
is at some point uh-oh this reminds me
of
um hikaru's win over magnus down upon
the start of the bishop of opposite
color
and rook's position but better bishop
better pawn structure
and he car's gonna try to win this one
rook g5 putting the bishop on f7 then
walk the king in start walking this king
in okay bishop v8
good idea buy bidded to try to get the
open line trade trade rooks i don't
think he can lose this game
i mean he can lose it time trouble is a
uh
thing but should not be losing though
white is about to have tons of pawns
moving forward
c5 presumably
it was b5 he played with two seconds
left by the way
c takes d4 bishop g2
king e6 or c6 nice move in the king e6
now it's a draw
bishop h1 bishop g2 back and forth keep
the king tied to the spawn
there's no way that white should be able
to make progress here
and this is just going to be a draw
there's not even really a winning
attempt here for white
okay you could actually push this pawn
oh oh my gosh is the car going to lose
this
this is what you call you know when you
get the tunnel vision of like oh i can
just do whatever i want
a car could lose this game here comes
this king
to the other side of the board but
bishop f8 that holds no no he's not
losing this
that's just complete draw so the point
is that bishop f8 bishop c5
is going to be the move for the rest of
the game right bishop f8 bishop c5
nothing you can do
the problem with opposite colored
bishops there's light square bishop
canon tackles pawn on b4
and we see just an easy draw they'll
play out forever
it is a draw for sure
and there's a draw okay
so do we have any games left in this
round we have a few we have
shigeru taking on demchenko and while
sugar was winning
so that puts him a seven out of nine and
that puts him in striking distance you
need to be
at eight and a half points when all is
said and done and at seven after nine of
course he can win his final game
and make his way there we have
tourniquets and
sunny kids with black down a pawn
against various of
kovalev and this should be a draw the
point is that when you play g4 this h
pawn takes
and then black just needs to sit the
king in the corner so the rook pawn
is not good in king and pawn end games
without
other pieces remaining so that's the
problem the rook pawn
and we saw it draw so heading into the
final round we
will have eight people move on to the
knockout so far we have a five-way tie
for first i expect those players to
do what they usually do and make some
quick draws and then all the way down to
12th place
is seven and a half points so actually
eight out of ten surprisingly has a
chance if you're sergey karjakin for
example
you can potentially qualify for the
knockout
but it's going to be relying on other
people's help
right you need some results from others
and here we go
so this game will be a draw in five
four three two
one okay they actually have to make the
moves around the start but i expect
the game to end in a very quick draw
let's see
and not yet at least not by mama jarv i
have not made a draw yet
where's parham he's probably already
made a draw didn't he oh
there we go a two move draw how
surprising
and parham is playing when do we think
this draw will happen
over under 10 moves
so far it looks kind of like a fight
we have this uh approach here where you
have the good central control for white
but black has the bishop hair the bishop
pair not exactly so
useful just yet especially this bishop
on c8 tends to be stuck behind pawns
and white has given up a pawn for the
time being so you give up this d-pawn
you leave it there and you operate
around it oftentimes you want to
try to put your bishop back on b1 and
get your queen to d3
not happening here so queen came to e2
the rook will come to d1 and you'll try
to go after the d-pawn in this manner
and the queen on e2 does a good job of
keeping the e5 pawn
protected so you can move your knight
out the way and then protect e5
but just a normal looking position thus
far i'm going to tune out of this one
i'm going to go to kamsky nakamura what
is this the us championship
of years past and hikaru has stole the
b2 pawn
dropped the queen back to a3 and not
good
that komski is spending quite a bit of
time here
uh sorry one sec
so uh yeah here are these
knights both of them pinned i guess
and white is trying to strike in the
center while black's king is
stuck there so parham did draw his game
no surprises and this one looking
interesting let's go to more games here
peter spidler he needs to get to eight
points just to even have a chance at
qualifying
his position is better with the black
pieces but we're not going to focus
on this one for too long let's focus
more on the top games
players fighting for eight and a half we
have pavel smirnov here
trying to take down shigeru swear with
the black pieces
he has this interesting setup it's
dynamic with pauses a5 and b4 which can
be
weak later in the game if i take on b4
and can pile up pressure here
but taking also opens up the a file and
a potential problem on the a4 square
so i think that both players are
probably sitting comfortably for now in
this position
oh i'm i'm told i left hikaru against
compsey right when komsky
blundered so i'm tuning back
and this is why i guess i shouldn't tune
away from games
what happened here oh my gosh the queen
a4 forgetting about a takes b5 and the
rook protects the queen
you hate to see that if you're a komski
fan or if your komski himself and now he
carries just up a piece
and completely winning so it's easy to
think that when you play this move queen
a4 let's go back in time again
that this pawn is pinned because it
usually is when the rook is undefended
but the queen protects the rook through
white's queen
and that's a free piece
so hikaru is going to win this game he
is going to move into the
knockout bracket i'm sure everybody's
thrilled about that except for the other
participants they
would have liked to see a car on the
outside and looking in
so hikaru unless something goes gravely
wrong here and
what could even go wrong i'm trying to
figure this out pawn on d6
okay that's something that i can claim
is
an advantage here so rook c1 please take
me on d6 i'll take back with my knight
your c5 knight will hang
and i could see a future if black isn't
careful where
white starts winning the a pawn start
liquidating
could have chances to hold sonny this
king is very happy to be sitting on
e8 and knight e4 is met by rook to beast
not rook b7 rook to b6
d7 what's that about
okay so rook d8 rook b7 bishop e7
knight c6 getting a little tricky
get an old triggy rook b7 there is
knight to d6 as well which
attacks the rook and defends f7 that's
good
and also protects the c8 square so if
you want to play rook c8 your rook is
defended back here
so f6 is a possibility and was just
played knight c6 rook c8
pinning this knight down to the rook
it's all happening
and after rook save the thread is knight
to b5 because knight b5 attacks the rook
and also threatens knight d4 check
exploiting the fact that the knight in
c6 is pinned
to the rook on c1 so it looks like
all variations favor hikaru here
and gotta he has to hope
it looks like a pipe dream at this point
and knight d4 check still
what a car is aiming for
so king d3 makes sense knight e7 forcing
things off
and once you trade everything on c6 you
have king d7 at the end
and that's that teeny 7 actually was
probably possible right away
but this is just simple here bishop d6
drop the bishop to c7
what are you doing you're losing the
sword comes to a8 wins the a4 pawn
you can also bring the rook to b8 to
just trade the rooks off because the
bishop and pawns vs king upon ending his
winning so rook b8 probably just does
the trick
he plays rook eight smart
okay so hikar's gonna win this let's go
back to
shigeru against smirnov what's happening
here
still locked up position on the queen
side you take on a4 at any point but
after b takes a4 that could be a
potential issue
it's even material
rook a3 what a move
what a move oh my gosh rook a3 just
planting the rook
uh there what a concept
just putting the rook here so you know a
queen a7 and you could take with the
pawn
and have an outside pass pawn
that is something
wow wow wow i mean just taking over the
board rook a1
here comes bishop f1 check
my gosh so let's see how to finish this
game though
i need to get my queen involved and i'm
looking at queen
over to h5 so he plays g5 first if you
take on g5
h takes hx in comes the queen to h7 that
would just result in a
checkmating attack would be disaster f5
played reinforcing
uh the square here now queen f7
threatens queen f3
but queen f7 queen h5 is also good
it looks like smirnov isn't taking this
one home bishop f1 queen entry is made
bishop one
and queen h3 is checkmate
queen she's still is checkmate because
you're going into g2 and
otherwise bishop any where's the bishop
go bishop d3 and made on f1
damn that was a cruncher crush
let's go back to karjakin he has no time
left but his position looks
pretty good and i'm looking at the
standings eight out of ten
right now he's tied for
[Music]
sixth place oh my gosh kayaking lost in
time
so liam vrolick is actually the one who
could potentially sneak in the field
eight out of ten karjatkins chances
of making the speeches championship
through the grand prix
they're gone and let's look at vivid
against kuzabov what's happening here
vidit
pushing his pawn going to eight and a
half points yes
sir and take on a5 move the knight back
a5
don't go a6 don't pre-move a6 by king b7
and then
the rest is easy
faded gujarati at eight and a half
points
let's see it i mean somehow he
lost pace with the leaders and he's
trying to
beat uh fanduerine van der reen i don't
know i pronounced his
username but that's mexican shigayev who
was closing
in on the fourth qualification spot from
the sec gp
he would have to win this game and do
well in the knockout that's not
happening
he loses on time and it's a mean time to
buy who
gets the victory so let's see eight and
a half points that's it
nope nobody else is making it in it
looks like the field is set
with the eight and a half point
performances
and let me just check to see if there
are other games remaining they probably
are
but they don't affect anything yeah
they're down to six now point territory
winning position knight g4 knight f2
and that allows the h1 to promote
so 89 points it's what was needed so
for kayaking even though he lost that
final game meant nothing
couldn't make it through anyway and
wow what a field we have we have
parham ponzilaya who's alex sir i
haven't checked yet
somebody tell me who alex sir is i can
try to look myself just so much effort
you know
try to figure out who alex sir is now
that's a zero chess i don't want you i
want
alex sir
who are you let's see oh federation okay
very strong russian grandmaster
so i think the field is set
and with that being the case going to
take a break so we can set everybody up
in the knockout when we return it will
be elimination time
and we know our field so get excited
hikara nakamura
everyone's going to be trying to knock
him out but he is an absolute force to
be reckoned with
week after week be right back everyone
patience is not a virtue
[Music]
it is a weapon
what's your wow rabbit
[Music]
so
and we do have an upcoming speeches
championship invitational
you can see the prize in front of you
first place being 1250
which is not a bad payday in addition to
qualifying for the main speeches
championship
follow chess.com social media and news
reports to find out more information
when it gets confirmed
but that will be a great event featuring
eight players vying for a spot
in the scc and speaking of vying for a
spawn in the sec
i imagine that our players from the
grand prix are just about
locked in because those that were on the
outside looking in i don't think they've
made their way to the knockout
so we'll have to get verification
whether hike marty rosen's
standing is confirmed because he was in
fourth place but not participating today
would be interesting to note how that
finishes off but we do have our eight
participants
for the knockout today uh parham
maxoudlu ends up in first place he gets
the one seed
and he takes on alexander ingesh who is
the eighth seed
so it's going to be interesting to see
all of these grandmaster
on grandmaster battles here no easy
matches
none whatsoever it's never going to be
the case when you're qualifying via the
swiss part of the scc here the gps are
just so tough
and hikaru nakamura locked in at the
fourth seed he faces levon panzulaya
and if he can beat uh that opponent in
the opening round then he'll
likely face oppar muksudo so you see in
front of you all matches
they're the fan favorite vita gujarati
he's the seventh seed the opposite side
of the bracket from mikara nakamura
and the uh he faced the two seat alexey
pre
uh roshini and shakur mama jarov
come on needs no introduction there one
of the best players in the world for
the last decade he takes on pavel
smirnov and smirnov
has been doing quite well in
recent events it seems like he's
really getting the hang of these online
formats so
very strong player from russia
let me just make sure that i am
following all these players
don't want to miss any of the action of
course so
you know we just make sure that when it
starts i'll be ready
and thus far i feel pretty ready for
these matches
what say you chat what do you think
about these match-ups
i'm sure everyone thinks hikaru is the
favorite
hard to argue with that but some of the
others may not be
so clear so what do you see as the final
matchup today i'm curious
your thoughts do you think it's going to
be hikara versus mama jarov
is mama jarv going to be knocked out
along the way
i don't know how could i be certain all
these players are so strong
all i know for certain is i want the
action to continue because i love
these speeches championship tournaments
so
fun quick pace a lot a lot to
cover all due start at once that is
correct
car reverse nakamura exactly the car
see a lot of video fans here
no surprise vitidopi
where's samaya is he
commentating on the action
but yeah we do have the format in front
of you is a three plus one time control
as has been the case uh throughout this
scc gp and then if they draw their game
it goes to a bullet game so
knockover's vidit would be height
yeah that would be pretty cool but i
don't know hikara is the first
round matchup that is no walk in the
park that's for sure levon panzerlaya
very tough competitor vita gujarati also
i mean
he's facing tough player after tough
play on his side of the bracket so i
would say that
no player is in the clear i mean para
maksublu
beat hikaru nakamura so we say hikaru
should be the favorite
but parham already beat him once today
and
as he is the number one seed he'll get
good odds against hikaru
so i'm glad you're enjoying the
commentary i really hope that's the case
so
just trying to figure out when these
games begin so i can continue
commentating
and stop trying to force you all to
make predictions okay the games are
about to start
so i'm getting word of and
well i'm excited for them here we see
the game
e4 no it plays c4 we get the english
opening instead
and these are three minute plus one
second increment time controls
it's going to be hard to flag any of
these players as they get that
second edge of their clock after every
move and h5 alpha zero style
we'll see if engine is really trying to
push that pawn forward or if it's just a
starting move
and his knight will come to h6 and f5 is
a typical plan here but parham ready to
play
the other side of the board with b4
challenging
black's queen side so i'm not sure about
this
voluntarily inducing a h3
and the knight on c3 is not defended so
b4 would be a blunder of course
but you can play bishop d2 first and
then play b4 so i'm not sure that this
actually helps black
and let's go on to hikara versus
ponzulaya oops
we uh see that he is
on the white side of this position he
has control of the d5 square
and we'll try to use the light scores to
his advantage that is what is
typical in these sort of night or
type positions it's not a night or it
was a con but you see this pawn on d6 so
you want to cement that pawn in place
and go after it so let's see here so
the bishop one c5 so far is defending
that pawn but you can play b4 bring this
knight into c4
and then it can be white as the
aggressor in this position
so let's uh keep on moving we'll go to
vidit's game against
me as that one is
taking place and look at this opening we
have a king's gamut you don't see that
every day but vidit plays e5
and prederogane plays f4 and bobby
fischer
must be very happy in his grave to see
this
because it is an adventurous opening the
pawn f4
is going to be recaptured unless
black tries a knight h5 type move and
said knight to e5 please take me on e5
help my pawn structure so that e5 is
attached to f4
instead he drops the bishop back and you
can play move like bishop to g4
the point being that hey like let me pin
your knight and take it and force you to
take with your g
pawn but white will recoup the pawn on
f4 which is why knight g6 was played
instead
by bidding that it is down quite a lot
of time here so he's moving slowly but
accurately
and according to the evaluation bar off
the side of the screen here
is liking this position slightly but
that can quickly turn around especially
if this king doesn't
get itself castled in the near future
so so far interesting games
all across them let's go back to the
parham game
against ingish and knight d5 was just
played so before we get back i just want
to see the next two moves here
because black has safely castled this
pawn is now defended on f4
and how is white actually going to get
that pawn back that's a tough question
to answer
black could play c6 to kick this bishop
out from d5 you could also play bishop
e6 and please take me
on e6 fix my pawn structure and f4 is
well defended for the time being
not a big fan of white's position but
parham he's in the midst of his game
against indic somehow black's pawn
structure has
become i double pawns the f-file
and we see what happened was
in the last couple moves this knight
went d5 e3 and just chopped the bishop
down so
thank you for your bishop you know take
back with your pawn good for you
and now you have a weak f5 point you
have this pawn on b7 if you ever you
take on d3 the diagonal opens up queen
a4 comes to mind in the near future as
well this is looking very sharp
and that is a very bad sign for engish
because white is the one with the bishop
pair
so c5 is immediately hanging queen f4 on
the docket f5
permanent weakness b file open every
single
aspect of this position favors white
including
time right now so it looks like parham
is cruising in this game
i'd be very shocked if he doesn't win
this game it looks so easy for him to
play
so let's keep on going here hikaru
nakamura
against levon ponculia i mentioned this
pawn on d6 earlier
it remains there but lavon doing a very
good job of coming after these
c the c pawn using the c file to his
advantage but uh oh
there is a vulnerable f5 square here
that looks like a problem what is the
knight in f8 doing
where is it going you need to cover this
f5 square i imagine
and so the knight back on e6 so that
when the knight gets to f5 you drop your
king
and bring your knight to g7 off of the
trade and then e6 would offer a trade in
both directions
if the knight came to d5 you put the
knight on c7
if the knight came to f5 you put the
knight on g7
but then f8 does absolutely nothing for
black's position
i don't think you have time to like
queen e6 knight d7 knight f6 things like
that it seems too slow
and 93 is still possible i imagine
because 93 rookie 4 i could probably
queen f3 and your rook is likely getting
trapped in the center of the board
so i would be concerned about black's
position here that's for sure
queen f3 comes to mind he does play
knight to e3 tactically saying this pawn
is sort of immune from capture and i
have received word that mama jarv wins
by forfeit his opponent just
went offline and didn't come back so
mama jarv moves on
to the semi-finals
and okay so rook c6 played wait queen
takes e5 check wasn't that a free pawn
oh gotta go back queen e5 d-e oh wait
look at me miss cal king there's a
knight there protecting so i'm
blundering pieces that are not mine
typical me and instead the queen came up
to g4 hitting the h5 pawn this
some potential for black to come back
here rook takes d6 though
do not take on c6 next because that
hangs d1 with check so that's why knight
g6 was played
take me i dare you not so fast d1 is
hanging
so you will not take on c6 instead
i could see a move like king g2
potentially play but then queen g4 is
quite a nuisance throwing knight f4 and
pinning the g3 pawn
so just need to be a little bit accurate
here that's all that's required as a
mattress
queen e4 is played g4
queen moves rook takes g6 could that
have been something to open up
the black king and g4 there's queen h3
that holds on
for now trying to figure out that like
finishing touch that's what i'm looking
for here
can i take on b7 and bring the next work
in
i can take mb7 this way but knight f4 is
the idea it feels like that kind of move
even if it should not work out it has
the potential to
cause some problems so the rook backs up
to f6
and okay i thought maybe rook to d6 and
trading the rooks training
feels like a good plan so rook f3 also
would trade rooks but there's knight f4
okay trading rooks from b6 makes sense
and the car looks like he's going to win
this game so we're going to move on from
ikaro's game
go back to some of the others parham has
two minor pieces for the rook he is in
fact
just crushing uh engish in this game
this pawn on f5 very strong don't play
f6 because that walks into
rook f5 rook takes f6 okay he does it
but i guess there's rook f3
so it does work out for parham
nonetheless
can't stop pawn f7 and this also can
capture on b6
the a takes v6 i think that black is
frozen over there but why not just
take a rook for a night when you can
take on h5 move your bishop back to e8
h pawn promotes game over so hikaru did
win his game let's go
to the vidic game because that's in a
rook end game that's much more
interesting much more life left as we
just see parham
win this one we have project against
vidit
is up two pawns in this end game
so he can just go king to b4 now okay
king b6 keeping his pawns
safe and sound brook takes h3 that's
three extra pawns per video he has 10
seconds to one
and he wins the game so
the quarterfinals i mean they wrapped up
pretty
quickly there so we're going to take
another quick break and we're going to
make sure that everything
is set for the semi-finals and when we
return we will see
parham against hikaru and vita gujarati
against mohammed europe you will not
want to miss the action
[Music]
and we have two players in the
semi-finals this
is taking on hikaru nakamura
it is in the top side of the bracket
parham the one seed hikara d4
they'll be playing a best of two little
mini match here in the three plus one
time control
if there's a tie they go to bullet and
the first winner in the bullet
wins the match up so the
games um we'll
start in about 30 seconds i'm being told
so just uh hold on for a quick second
there
and we will get this matchup going and
parham he did defeat ekkar nakamura
in the swiss portion of the event hikaru
is obviously
a tremendous player and just because he
lost once earlier
he in fact might be angry about that and
will look to
seek his revenge
so we're just waiting for the game to
start any second now
and parham he did choose black to start
he has the higher seed he gets to choose
color and we have
game in motion so we have a spanish
we've seen this
from the car a lot and we saw it earlier
today in their match and hirocarp is
knight to d2 so you have to watch out to
make sure the e5 pawn isn't falling
and typically there are queen d4 type of
tricks but parham says
let me just make sure that i'm not
driving upon ever queen e7 defends
don't be playing bishop e6 or something
like that to drop the pawn
so um
so let's see and is the first game of
the semifinals here
so knight c4 okay this is very typical
you're going after the e5 pawn black
retrieves the knight to d7 so you can
play f6 or even f5 depending on how
white
continues his approach here because if
you castle and can play f5
that does harm your e5 palm maybe
creates a nice little pawn but there are
times when that is worth it
so first you probably want to develop
make sure everything
is connected and safe and sound before
ever making move like f5 and you're not
getting f5
because hikaru was trying to fill the
square with his knight and we saw him do
this earlier
this knight came out to b6 so that when
knight f5 happened
parham took on that square but this time
he plays knight to f8 so he's not going
to take on f5 i don't think
he'll first move his queen away to f7
unless you can just take on
f5 and i saw the evaluation for a jump
so perhaps there was some kind of bishop
takes f5
and queen to d7 for example but instead
we have seen a trait on e3
and now f takes e3
this knight can come to e7 this knight
can try to come to h4
maybe like a slight little pull but it
doesn't feel like there's anything
major happening just yet so
hikaru on the white side this position
hasn't obtained all that much if you
play d4
you have to watch about the e4 pawn so
first
card drops the knight back to d2 opens
up the f file
maybe trying to react the knight over to
the queen side so
where can you go for this knight nowhere
the bishop can capture it no matter
where it goes and this knight can come
back to e7 to challenge the knight f5
so it's just a game of tense
repositioning and i just don't see how
either side is
planned to make progress anytime soon a
car tripling on the f file
but what next you know is he gonna play
g4 h4 h5
oh that was a committal decision by
parham i don't like his decision at all
this queen can actually
snake into the queen side at some point
obviously g5 is
what's coming up soon rook g2 g5 knight
to e4
i don't like what parham did there take
out f5 felt
not just premature just actually wrong
and he's interpreted knight on d6
and here comes pawn to e4 protecting f5
another time
getting g5 ready so it wasn't just about
placing a knight on e4 which is probably
good
but now it's at the pawn me4 and black
is very restricted here
and the side that controls the pawn
breaks is often the side of the
advantage here it's clear
white controls the pawn breaks with pawn
and g5 and king h2 over g1 pawn g5 so
is black one played b5 very risky
decision no he plays
g5 hoping to shut down the initiative
that's happening on this flank but that
looks super risky
he car smartly takes on poisson opens up
the f line
this pawn here h5 or g5 both moves you
have to keep an eye out on
g5 mail out f5 so probably not so fast
on that one
but i'm sorry i clicked that square that
was not hikara that was me but queen e3
and this rook can slide up to f3 and
maybe even over to the h file depending
on what's happening here
not a fan of parliament's position and
the card doing very well on the clock
he's nearly two minutes two pounds
minute and fifteen seconds so what can
you do you probably have to defend
quite passively for the time being h5
still a possibility you have to think
about the repercussions of if the pawn
charger gets locked up h5 g5
now h5 there's knight g5 so that's
actually a very good square for the
knight to get to
because the knight wants to get to e6
and into f4 so g5 is just step
one as i reposition the knight to f4 so
knight
otherwise come in d8 e6 and d4 and f4
are available so actually i'm starting
to appreciate black's position
a bit more now as parham he's making it
happen here comes the knight
and i don't know where he cards it has
to be on d5 before that night gets to f4
but you don't have time for it
96 you can't play knight jumping into
the d5 square and times like queen f2
knight e6
93 you're a step behind so knight g3 is
their knight of five
that's the big question here is their
knight f5 and i guess the knight of five
you can just
move your queen to h7 do not play queen
to f7 because that would walk into
knight h6 with a check
and a fork so instead the knight comes
back
over to e2 and is it time for the king
run
is it time to dart that king over to the
queen side
i think so i don't like my king here i
also like getting my rook to h8
and hitting the h4 pawn
so i think it's time to play king f7 not
an easy move
to play usually but here i see my rook
on f8 doing a good job of defending f6
so my king going that way it does make
sense g5
clearly trying to get this knight into
f4
and we see a capture and now pawn takes
oh this looks problematic though this
looks not so good for
black you don't want to take on f5
because then you stay with either pawn
honestly
so you're trying to keep the position as
close as possible but it feels like
white's pieces are just a little bit
more active
rook h6 can be met by
can i go knight h5 because you take with
the knight the g5 pawn hangs
oh my gosh there's a lot to calculate
really a ton here
i have the feeling that black should be
okay but
kind of walking on eggshells and he
needs a move
he plays rook h6 ultimately i think is a
good choice
knight h5 takes as i mentioned the g5
pawns hanging rook takes g5
take it and then rook g6 you take
this rook on uh h5 and it protects the
g5 rook so
i think you're getting away with it but
there is rook four at the end of this
it's not as easy as i initially made it
seem
and brooke g5 rook g6 rook h5
rook f4 trying to close this queen off
in the defense of the g5 square
it's becoming really intense
in this position so he takes with the
pawn on h5 the knight takes
h5 so he got pre-moved and i guess the
claim is that e5 and g5 are weaker than
f5 and h5
so king h7 queen e4 maybe just to
threaten f6 check the queen blockades
but the queen
doesn't want to sit on f6 queens are
notoriously bad block haters
so this pawn is hanging on e5
so trades okay but this
c7 pawn is a big problem but if rook h2
rook at e7 rook h7 rookie seven uh-oh
black lily's surviving he gets his king
to walk back here
so rook f7 now go after the f5 point
rook g7
okay king f8 also works i guess because
the king can just start marching up
well that was a good move though f6 and
rook h7 found so quickly by parham
take this and it should almost certainly
be close to a draw but i would be
careful if i were hikaru because if this
king somehow
can oh candy five rookie four very
important move because if that king
could get to d4
all of a sudden it's black who's trying
to win this game
so yeah this is just a draw at this
point
so draw a greed parham once again with
the black pieces
staves off any sort of pressure that
hikaru nakamura brings him he won the
first game he drew
this one and now parham gets white the
issue for parham
is that in bullet obviously hikaru has
to be the favorite
it's just first to win a gaming bullet
so not so
easy to say that icar will definitively
win that but he is a bullet
machine and in blitz well
hikaru should be the favorite here too
but parham's been playing a really nice
day of chess
all right so knight to g5 this is
typical berlin situation here
um the knight captured on e6 you take
back with the pawn not a big deal but
here the knight came to d4
and i think parham has to be a little
bit careful knight takes e6 you can take
with the f
pawn and i was mentioning that's
perfectly fine for black often
it's actually helpful you get yourself a
semi open f file this pawn e5 is one
that
has over extended itself in many
variations so i do think that we will
see 96 because rook to c1 is met by
bishop
f5 and that's going for the c2 pawn
so i think it now is the time to play
knight takes e6 get rid of the bishop
pair
and maybe you're not in an advantageous
position
but you just say you know they got to do
what i got to do
so knight caption e6 to keep the pawn
shutter attack g6
stops f5 if you play g4 i welcome the
opening of the h file so it says g3
first
that was king g2 king f3 and bench you
play for g4
if you did not play g3 black would have
played h4
so that you could ah you could take on
poisson if that pawn ever tries to move
someone said g3 is played so h4 is met
with g4 don't be playing h4 that just
helps white out
and here bishop c3 pawn 63 the claim is
that
you've double isolated my queen side
pawns not that big a deal my king side
paw majority is more important
because you have isolated not excuse me
double pawns of your own
this is the maximum sheila grav
treatment of this opening
we've seen in players a number of times
and doubling
isolating your own pawns i guess is not
the most important thing here
so here we see here i should say the
sirens likely
for the pawn structure to be and the car
was thinking before playing
will he take on c3 will he bring his
king up to e7 to connect the rooks
so that one of them can go to the d8
square will they start with rook to d8
looks like a very good and natural move
it's just all coming down to his
decision making is he going to take on
c3
and we see hikaru grabbing his head deep
in thought there trying to figure out he
plays
f5 what a concept it shuts down
g4 it says if you do not take me on
poisson which you
can only do right now and that's what
harm does
if you do not do that the structure gets
shut down and the
knight in the light square shows the
issue with the bishop of dark scores the
knight can't be kicked out but here
bishop
d4 will probably force off a trade and
then the f6 pawn hangs at the end there
so it's just a series of trades that
should still be beneficial for white
because then i've just plugged my rook
on the e5 square i know that's a lot to
visualize but
if you can imagine a capture on d4 the
pawn gets here
you've just actually helped my rook
stabilize on the e5 square
so the rook is coming to e4 that's the
idea
and this rook is coming to e8 do not
take on h f6 excuse me
take out 6 would be a big mistake
because you're walking into
a discovery this 96 needed to be
defended first
okay so how to push 40 you can play g4
at now or any moment
um i okay g4 was played
you better be careful because g5 would
protect that past pawn
and if king f6
is there anything here like if i move my
bishop to h4
that looks like a normal decision to get
the bishop out there
okay brings his king in first maybe
he'll play king f3 and then bishop to
f2 but i want to get my bishop to h4
because by having the bishop on h4
you're pinning the knight in a way
because the rook could come to e7
if this bishop were on h4 so just trying
to reposition
improve the location of that bishop
first but as we see here hikaru
has handled this very well expertly and
i don't think that black is worse in
fact i'd probably take black based on
the pawn structure on the
queen side one issue is that if you want
to actually
make progress you would love somehow to
get your rooks like a6 or a5 but your
pawns are in your way
so king f3 taking back on for the k is
the king trying to get all the way up
here
that seems too risky so if takes takes
brook replaces rook on e8
is the king going to d5 it's possible
certainly possible i just don't like
walking into pins
although bishop can retreat and offer an
exchange of rooks so maybe it's not so
bad
so hickory thinking here he does take
he'll play rookie a check
and maybe king f3 so you can play rook
h1 next and try to free up your rook
he plays it there's nowhere from black
to infiltrate right d2 is covered by
this bish 23 king g3 now
okay bishop two saying similar here you
can't get in
but if knight e6
it's not threatening anything like has
the look of a good move and it's played
but bishop g3 and watch out for f5 do
not blunder f5
with bishop e5 check so his rook h7 very
smart move
now is he preemptively defending the c7
pawn he's saying if you play f5 and
check me here
so what my rook is no longer on the h8
square which would have been a problem
and if you're swinging rook to d1 same
issue you can't get in
there's nowhere to get in the position
so rook
e5 trying to play f5 that's a good try
k plays f5 now knight g5
check there's king even king f4 there
and i would have to go to h3 and that
knight does not want to be on h3
you could play king e3 as well it's a
matter of taste i guess but
otherwise where's his knight going takes
you take with a rook
don't want to lie that maybe knight g7
just trying to take on f5 and not like
two with the rook so it plays in that g5
check
king e3 right away okay i would have
thought of putting the king on f4 first
rook f5
kg6
and bishop f4 bishop h4
my bishop h4 i don't want to allow
bishop 496 attacking the bishop
even though black cannot afford to trade
minor pieces often
because now i have an extra pawn on the
king side and all the other pawns are on
the queen side but
bishop h4 knight
h7 maybe just to defend the f6 square i
don't really like the look of knight h7
so playing that f7 saying i don't care
about rook check let's just one check
okay king f4 g5 all right
you didn't want to bring the king up if
you bring the king up too far then the
rook start
starts coming down or knight d6
and i don't think you want to allow a
rook trade if you live work trade the
king will block on the light square
here comes the rook for the pawn so king
g4 bishop e5 that's what i want to
accomplish here
so takes bishop e5 there's knight c4
maybe wait can i take on d6
oh so writes up a pawn
check here takes takes i think we're
liquidating
rook f2 check oh oh now this
okay so this is going to be tough a4 c4
check oh that's immediately
wait can you have five and that's the
drum you have the six rank defense just
rook a6 now
yeah it's a drug parham was really
trying gear he was pressing him
couldn't make it work though
and they make a draw so we're about to
have a bullet game between these two
and wow that was i mean this moment here
with a4 i guess that was a
mistake and probably rook a6 or
something like that just keeping the
pawn protected was a better way
to try and win the game but black likely
would have just pushed the pawn down
like move the rook push the pawn
and eventually it probably was just
going to end in a draw
anyway so nice try there by parham
hikaru did show some great defense
and parham now has to take him down a
bullet here we go i'll try to be
useful while they're playing bullet
chess all right
so symmetrical structure 97 so you can
play c5 in the near future he puts
knight to b6 stopping c4 so instead of
playing
4c5 this is a pure bullet game no
increment here so c4 good setup so far
for parham
and good time management for hikaru all
right a4 so you can play a5 and maybe
even a6 to
try to get at this pawn on c6
so a5 a6 still on the docket here and a
car is moving quite
slowly considering his typical speed c3
nice move
you don't allow the pawn to get on c34
and try to keep the pawns together
now this is a target here but e3 is
coming so
there's also a6 coming so if c5 is a6
you have to be very careful about that
and h4 seemed a little irrelevant okay
h5
not sure where his pawn's going here
because
e4 was never working because the d4 pawn
would have fallen
and i think you take this at some point
you consider taking on
e5 because
if you get this double pawn it can
blockade the situation then
uh this can turn around very quickly the
knight can be better than bishop but
rook c2
is something that one needs to be
careful about
i still don't like the look of bishop
takes e5 that's why i went knight to d3
they're very smart by parham
but he's down 10 seconds here no no he
car is way too fast
how in the world can he can he hold this
game his position is fine objectively
but now it's about the clock bishop a3
bishop takes d6 oh my gosh we should be
five he won a piece
oh no he didn't he won and said the
queen
for uh two rooks and
can you find 95 97. he said take us but
hit cars too much time here so it should
be totally fine for white
or maybe black's going to have blacks
winning is winning on the board and on
the clock
bishop a3 rook c6 for c1 that's game
over
take take bring the rook back around
somehow
bishop e5 is possible c4 check
can't take on b2 after rooks before
his car was too good the car was way too
good what a beast
what an absolute monster there wasn't a
moment there
where i saw the evaluation bar jump so
let's go to that moment
i know that parham didn't have too much
time
so bishop d6 rook c1 bishop e5
didn't like so it wasn't just like
rooksy one rook d6 and
i guess some kind of it's kind of like
rook c7 or something
you know this is a positional way of
going for a win here looks good it's
hard to play with no time in your closet
just when you see bishop e5 you go for
that the tactical sequence
you're down a lot it car was 33 53 in
bullet chest
oh boy that's uh that's pretty high
pretty high so
anyway this didn't happen this indeed
instead did and parham was able
to net himself this rook for his knight
but now black has a rook a bishop and a
pawn for the queen that's lasker
compensation
and you're never going to survive
against a car when you have nine seconds
left
so yeah
by the way mama jarv has chosen the
black pieces to start
his match against avid gujarati
so mama jarov takes the black pieces
this is typical
in high level play in a two game little
mini match starting with black so you
know what you need with white so if you
lose the game with black
you say let me take a more aggressive
approach give myself more winning
chances
if you win the game with black you can
just take a calmer approach maybe try to
find a forcing sequence
and if you draw well you get the white
pieces you can do what you want
okay we're about to have go time here
between
uh gujarati and mamanjaro so as soon as
that game
begins i will pull it up
so almost there almost ready
and as mentioned mama jarv starts with
the black pieces he made his way to the
semi-finals his opponent just didn't
even
show up in the quarterfinals he didn't
know about the
knockout portion of things that was
pavel smirnov but either way mama jarov
deserving participant here
in the final four
and we have a game
so bitter choose d4 no surprise that is
his
main weapon and will we get a king's
indian when we get a grunfeld the
answer is in front of us we have a
grunfeld we were talking about peters
fiddler earlier he is
a renowned grunfeld theoretician and
won the world's if not the world's
leading expert on the grunfeld the point
for black is you've given up control
over the center in the sense of the pawn
placement white has an additional pawn
in the center compared to blacks one
but look at how quickly you can apply
pressure on that center
and in the end game once we trade on d4
i have a
two on one majority for black so central
control
in white's favor the end game the two on
one
all the way on the queenside flank over
there is beneficial for
black but it doesn't make its relevance
felt for
quite a bit of time because look at
white's rook on c1
it's can land on c7 at some moment the
d4 and e4 pawns are still very strong
restricting for example this bishop on
c8 it goes to e6 thank you
i go to d5 i just kick your bishop back
so black's pieces don't exactly have the
nicest squares to go to knight c6 can be
met by d5 at some point
so that's why the pawns in the center
are good your pieces belong in the
center
pawns are restricting your pieces that's
that
so if i'm playing as mama jarv here i'm
trying to figure out not just a move but
a plan he plays knight c6 here comes d5
and then i believe the knight should go
to okay let's say e5 it goes to b4
going after this pawn but wait a sec
that knight's not getting out
if you take on a2 rook c2 happens and
your knight gets trapped
on a2 so this looks like a
mistake by mama jarv we have him on
camera i'm looking at his reaction there
then it looks like he's like under a
onesie or something
he looks so cozy there and
he's just hanging out and mamadiarov is
looking quite stressed
and well you don't want to go 96 i think
that it can
take it on a6 instead plays knight a5
first
trying to take on a6 plug that knight on
c6
so things still looking good for vita
gujarati
and both these players above twenty
seven hundred feet of course
mama jar have been a top ten fifteen you
know he goes up to number two in the
world and back down to say number
fifteen i'm not sure
of his exact rating at this moment but
he's been an elite player
for over a decade and for
vita gujarati he's you know making his
way
up there he's obviously very very strong
he captained the
indian team at the
online olympiad and he's played many
events this summer
but he hasn't quite made it to that 2750
level
that's not a criticism it's just fact so
we're looking for vida to make that push
when more over-the-board chess resumes
you know when the pandemic hopefully
subsides
then we'll see if he's able to make his
way up even more
but right now he has a great position
with white pieces he's up a minute and
20 seconds on the clock
so he understands these positions
extremely well
and mama jarvis is struggling because
now if you play e6 i can probably take
you
the bishop can't take back because the
pawn on b7 needs a
defender so b6 played in comes the
knights of c6 very quickly
and this rook will go to d7 it's not the
end of the world for mama jarv it
doesn't look
awesome but it looks okay he's just
trying to hold down the fort for the
time being
here it comes and this knight can try to
come
to c5 to put pressure on the e4 pawn
looks like a standard plan of action
bishop e3 saying you're not getting a c5
without recapturing you
and that also makes sense because if i
can steal a pawn
even if you have compensation you need
to prove that it's sufficient for
equality because con compensation excuse
me is
the term that sometimes doesn't amount
to what you may think it does
this rook on a8 is a bit stuck the a7
pawn can be hanging in many variations
so i would be worried about that
bishop c6 does not look good no matter
the line
you would take hitting the rook but this
knight is also a problem
so can i play knight d4 96 check
no because you can take on d4 with your
bishop
i wanted to you're not you're assuming
your rook is protected on c7
i wanted to like reroute this knight
really quickly
and that would be good under other
circumstances but
it doesn't quite work out maybe it's
fine to
trade on d4 square but it's not
quite what i wanted and
thinking here he has plenty of time to
do so up
about um 50 seconds on the clock
how to make progress bishop f4
comes to mind hitting this rook here
uh what else the reason i don't like
bishop f4 is it takes away your control
of c5 square but
maybe that's worth it you can take on f5
g takes play bishop d3 and just swing
your attention to this
king side that looks pretty interesting
but whenever you take on
f5 or push upon e5 the d5 pawn becomes a
little bit looser
so you do have to think about that as
well
but i'm looking at e takes a five now so
it's catching my attention
it looks like a good chance to net a
pawn if you are a bit of gujarati
there is a one second increment this
time which was three minute plus one
second increment
and vid it using so much of his time he
does take on f5
and mama jarv had that pre-moved he knew
that was happening
and he plays knight to d4 but now isn't
this d5 pawn just hanging
so okay it's not actually hanging yet
because the 986 is under attack
okay so for the time being that it has
it under control
but if rook c7 knight c7 then the pawn
excuse me the pawn here is really a
problem the bishop
and the knight atlanta c7 are both
teaming up on it
so bishop d3 he takes his attention this
way he took the rook on c7 that's
interesting because the bishop can't
take on d5 the knight a6 is hanging
knight to b4 drops the pawn to f5 and h7
is hanging after that
so what white really wants is i'll take
f5 and then push the pawns but here
now this rook is captured on d5 would
hit the bishop on f5
and the bishop one d4 bishop takes f5 so
you have to be careful here
you have to be careful rook once was
rook d5
oh [__] 56 he plundered it and bishop
g7 check
a huge blunder by mama jarov he loses an
exchange
you tip the knight on a6 to distract the
bishop away and now after rook d7 e7 and
a7 were in tech
take here and rook b7 and vidic winning
this game
fitted gujarati is winning thanks to a
huge miscalculation
by mom and jarv when they're rooks in a
row you have to be very careful
and maybe i'm speaking too soon is it
quite winning b3
king e3 you get your king here first and
then put your rook on b7 so i think you
are in time to play king e3
here you go bring the king closer you
also play f4 check if you need to
and get your rook on over to b7 f4 check
okay bring king d2 first i like putting
the pawn on dark square
and that's why mama jarva is trying for
some kind of bishop one but rook g7 does
the trick
and after rook g7 the h pawn roams
it frolicks to the other side
wow what a one move
turn around there i mean brook takes d5
right here just not recognizing the
danger of rooks in a row
so vidit gets the black pieces oh mama
jarv ran away
where'd he go
he's back
i don't know if he realized the game was
starting so quickly but vidit takes that
one
and now with the black pieces mama jared
playing
this variation with the queen drops back
to d3 okay and the bishop can drop
in on the g5 square or d2 i don't know
these lines really that well and hence
why i'm saying moves like bishop to g5
it looks like a normal move but there
probably are some tactics
by taking on c3 on e4 the bishop run g5
so knight e2
all right so white's position is very
compact here
i think f3 makes sense keep everything
in a line
instead he plays bishop g5 h6 the bishop
drops back to h4
the knight on e2 protects the other
knight so bishop c3 queen c3 then knight
takes c4 would make sense
but you can take back on c3 with the
knight and this knight to e5
then bring the knights to g6 it feels
like a very vivid type of maneuver
so i wouldn't be looking at that but
they need to watch out for bishop takes
f6 and knight to d5 at some point
because that would hit the queen and the
bishop at the same time but of course
the queen on
d3 was under attack first okay
knight d5 coming watch out c6 a
possibility here
takes takes knight g6 and if knight d5
is knight takes e4
tactics everywhere in such a position
but vidiq says i'm not
forcing anything i'm going to be com
play c6
um knight g6 will get this bishop off
the board but now the d6 pawn is weaker
the bishop does cover it for the time
being but you have to keep an eye on
that
i think a3 makes a lot of sense because
either black takes on c3
or plays bishop a5 but in either way the
d6 pawn
becomes more of a target so i think that
mama jarv is doing the right thing
and f4 knight g6 e5
getting hectic over here but i don't
think it actually
works out because f3 instead uh just to
show very quickly f4 here e5 you can
make use of the pin but knight h4 ef6 is
the movie you want to play
but there's queen takes f6 and i'm
protecting my knight so that wouldn't
work out
so instead f3 was played and for
vidit he needs to find a move here
knight g6 does hang this pawn on d6 was
just talking about that
that doesn't look good suppose queen e7
so now if knight g6 and you take on d6
i will be able to take on h4 my queen
isn't hanging in that variation
but there will be bishop f6 and then
take on d6 but
as is usually the case the bishop pair
that black
obtains gives good compensation so b5
protects the c4 square if you want to
jump there but also clearly threatens to
use
the a3 as a hook to play b4 open this
position up but rook's coming to b8
and voila that's a quick attack so if
i'm mama jarv you should be very careful
not even
to need to win this game so you have to
figure out a way to do that but i need
to be careful not to lose the game
as well knight a2 just stopping before a
clear
retreating move and i think it's obvious
now what he's trying to accomplish
and knight g6 comes to mind i know i'm
hanging in d6 but i said maybe that's
okay bishop c7
watch out for d5 okay
d5 you can just capture it
g5 does not pin this and obviously
you're not pin does not win this bishop
on h4 because the pawn is pinned to the
king there may be a sack right there or
f4
you don't play movie g5 unless you're a
thousand percent sure and then it won
the first game of this
two game match so why should he risk it
with a movement g5
bishop d7 that allows c5 in some
variations but the pawn b5 is still
under attack
because the bishop on f1 is there but
you may want to sacrifice
this pawn on b5 to open up the b file
typical plan
so vidit he's bopping a little bit
i think he's stretching maybe dancing
i'm not sure
either way he looks like he's in good
shape he's also up nearly 20 seconds on
the clock
there's no way for white to easily break
through queen came back to f2
a5 looks pretty decent trying to play
for b4 and attack
knight g6 i've mentioned that move many
times
at this point and knight h5 gets you the
bishop he plays a4 i like that move
because knight before
was surprisingly annoying going after
the c6 one
okay so h4 has been played trying to go
h5 bishop h4 get that pin back
he's in it to pin it where's dino diskey
and i said it only because it's vidit
but that has a tough one
i have to be hard on myself just like i
am my co-commentators so h5 95
bishop h4 here comes some pressure is
there a g4 g5 happening anytime soon
not so fast okay but c5 now you give the
b5 square so this is not
what vidit wanted and this pin is so
frustrating how do you deal with that
maybe bishop d he like a very sad
retreating move
because that way you can move your queen
out the way he instead tries to take
matters into his own hands with d5
and ed5 he can't take with the knight
either stick with the pawn give himself
an isolated pawn
this bishop then gets the b5 square
i'm not feeling that i'm not feeling
this one bit
maybe bishop b6 somehow keeps his knight
on a2 out of play but the knight is
trying to reroute some
to c1 to b3
so okay
now the pin is gone so if you take on
the uh
d7 i can take with this knife but then
knight f5 so be very careful you do not
want this knight landing on f5
especially if you can get into e7 next
with this knight on f6 captures back
and then f5 then promotes ideas like g4
and just
blasting through over here on the king
side
this does not look good did it
in more time trouble than his opponent
under pressure over the board as well
and queen b6 now if you take on b5 then
i can still capture on b5 the bishop
remains for defends
so that's not a good thing either it
feels like everything i say is
beneficial for
mahmoud jarv and except for the clock
he's down at 16.5 seconds
that's not good that's not good at all
and h5 can be captured at some point and
he captures it right now
he has no fear he stole the pawn and
then i can come into f4 that looks like
a good
decision here comes knight f4 right now
and then maybe the e
knight can try to come to g6 but you'd
have to take on b5 first bishop b5
oh this that comes to c4 actually this
is a big issue in knight g2
we'll hit the bishop and hit the rook
here's knight c or knight f3 oh
gosh i didn't even see that that's
everything
everything is hanging and vidi is just
mopping up right now
and he wins on time so gujarati
defeats mama's yard two to nothing
and dang that was a performance that was
extremely impressive
we know our final match up it is hikaru
nakamura it is vita gujarati
we're gonna take our final break and
when we return we will have the matchup
that everybody's been clamoring for
in the speeches championship grand prix
brought to you by chess.com
[Music]
and you can see how these two super
grandmasters made their way to the final
hikaru nakamura beat levon panzolia then
edged out paramag sulu the top seed
in a bullet game video gujarati has been
unscathed in the knockout beating alexey
pederojni and then
sweeping chakra mamajara of a bit of a
surprise there mama jarov
is a superstar but in the first game it
was getting to a position
towards the end game and well it looks
like
his tactics were sharper in game two as
well in the time scramble it was vidit
who
looked like the powerful player that he
is and now he gets to face
as his reward hikaru nakamura for first
place
in this knockout both these two players
stellar
ambassadors of the game of chess been
streaming a ton lately made it on
youtube
a car on twitch and we are just
making sure that the players are set up
and
i'll be getting the word on who gets
white in the first game remember it is a
two game
mini match of three minute plus one
second increment and
um looks like hikaru
is taking the white pieces if i'm not
mistaken so
hopefully these games take off soon and
we'll get to the chess
because you know me i'm always excited
for some awesome
speed chess great games to commentate on
and well that it is just
looking to upset if you will another
super grandmaster
back to back so
now it's hard to say in these uh
online chess events because vidit is a
powerhouse himself
but mama jarov in terms of least over
the board chess has the higher of the
two
ratings and ah i was wrong nick hickar
has
black to start with so he gets black in
the first game
and so vid it will try to
prove the first move advantage here try
to take an initiative
you do not want to lose with the white
pieces we saw
you know we've seen what happens in
those cases you lose the white and you
somehow win with black not so easy
so for vidit you want to make the most
of
this in the opening game and for hikaru
well
you're kind of chilling we saw his
approach against parham xulu two draws
are okay with him because he is the
favorite
in the bullet
so we are going to have the games begin
right now
here we are so bit it white pieces plays
d4
we saw him do the same against mama jarv
and will we get a king's indian no we
will not we will get
maybe a nimzo let's see how pita
continues here knight c3
typical bishop b4 after that no we see
knight f3 and d5 so we have the qgd
and we're going to get a catalan here we
go the bishop of the long diagonal
please take me on c4 that's
what has been asked and answered sure
you asked me to i will
so this bishop on g2 would love to
remove that bishop on c6 out of the way
but the problem is not easy to do that
you're not going to accomplish that
and this is the line i believe where
black takes an f3 and plays c6
so you take on f3 the bishop takes back
you play c6 and you claim that you have
a brick wall on the queen side here it
is exactly the sequence
and opposite color bishops white has
slightly more space but black has great
control over this b4 square
so that's the good news for black
control the b4 square no targets
to exploit but white just has more space
and
considering how quickly vid has been
playing this i feel like
maybe he has a little something up his
sleeve here because
black generally speaking shuffles around
a bit doesn't really do much of
anything you know if you place you can't
play c5 it opens up the bishop you can
think about playing e5
but that has ramifications that you'll
have to deal with as well
so hikaru
i think we'll put a rook on d8 maybe f
to d8 keep this rook on a8
he plays e5 okay i thought d5 now is the
move
because takes bishop takes and what
ideally you get
is if this black knight takes you on d5
you end up putting your own knight on
the light square and this bishop on d6
can't attack you
that's exactly what we're seeing maybe
maybe there was potential for knight c3
first but
instead it takes back on d5 that was the
first one i said bishop can go back to
g2
and now the light square bishop is
better than knight so that's the problem
for black in these type of positions
it's not that white is much better but
why is a little pull
no matter the trades that we get if we
take on uh
c three minus knight gets there i have a
slight pole thanks to the quality of my
bishop on g2
and now if i go knight d5 this could be
a slightly better
um bishop of opposite color intense
queen and rook's middle game because the
problem on f7
is greater than any problem that white
has but black is still holding in all
these lines
i think you have to try 95 though and
they're the sirens
i know there they go um
it's not for any player's chances here
looks pretty
fine so far hey car looking like he's
having to time his life cracking up
i don't know what that's about
so a car is having a blast
and vidit seems to be really
laser focused on the center of the board
here and i guess that's what it was
about he decides to trade
one pair of rooks and this rook would
love to get to c6 and start trying to
get in the position but bishop c5 now
says
nope no progress for you and the pawn
can be e4 to reinforce his bishop to
keep it
solidly in place but we play e4 black
could play f5 and say hey my bishop
is now open up as well so i think this
game
in all likelihood will be a draw i think
they'll split the point
i'm not quite sure how white intends to
improve the position from this point
f7 is defended queen
defends b6 you can play bishop e7 or d8
you can play e4 and check the queen to
f3 check
i don't see what did it
could possibly do here i think it's
totally fine
so bishop e7 allows for work to d8 next
and swapping the rooks results in
immediate
quality uh rookie 6 or d6 as well nice
and if rook d7 you play with e7
if rookie 6 or d6 you can try to do that
rookie 6 rook d7 there still is rook d6
because you can take on f7 with check
but i can take you back because once
this rook gets to d6
it's a problem down the d file so i
dropped the rook on the square it means
to
play bishop e7 going for the rook swap
next move and i think we'll see a draw
green
i'm doing well thank you for asking see
you i see you on the chat thanks for
everybody who's tuned in right now
we just have two games to go this one
uh and if we get a winner in the next
one then it's all over before we go to a
bullet tiebreaker and the first to win a
bullet game
wins the match so vidit is
trying to pretend like he has something
here
but it's a whole lot of nothing the
queen and the bishop doing a great job
of covering
these pawns aren't dark squares which
means the bishop one c4 can't get there
okay these pieces all under attack
but so what how can you make progress
here maybe f4 at some point
doesn't look real plays it
and this queen can probably continue to
go back and forth from e7 to c7
so
h4 takes do not take with the queen
that's how you drop a pawn and that
could be a problem even there actually
isn't so bad the nature of the opposite
colored bishops
should be totally fine for black
sticks with bishop of course and now
white is up a pawn
so he's pretending hey i've got the
extra pawn all is good here
but the queen's still coming to e7 and
maybe into f6 that pawn moves the queen
can come into g5
yeah this is nothing hold on nothing
and i wonder if icaru could start
thinking about playing for a win because
he is
well ahead in the clock and
you know if at a certain point you
realize hey i can't really lose
so why don't i play on and try to see if
i can swindle one
wouldn't be that surprised like queen f5
here
trying to get over to c2 perhaps e4 not
an easy move to play when you give up
more of the dark squares or queen f3
queen c2 check king f1 yeah it's a draw
both players know that it's a draw
but no harm in trying to
just steal a victory and no he'll trade
him enough to now i think
yeah he realizes there's nothing here
and draw agreed
okay so game two now if there's a winner
the match is over if they draw their
game we get
a bullet game to decide this we're
getting
oh is he taking him to bullet he card
did this on purpose he wants bullet
and you could see him trying to hold
back a smile and vidit's like oh no
oh no oh no here we go
here here's the the draw that
everybody has seen many times car did
this against magnus
if he feels like it favors him to get
rid of this game he's going to do it
and it does favor him because we get the
bullet so for video gujrati he can enjoy
his couple rating points that he earned
from this draw but he's probably not
thrilled about entering the bullet and
you see him
taking a deep breath there stretching
the neck
it all comes down to this bullet game
unless they draw in which case we get
more bullet
here comes the 1-0 all right visit with
the black pieces will we see
a car go for e4 oh
what just happened
okay i guess car wasn't ready
and does vinnie get the white pieces
because he was the higher seed right
wasn't it car visited the three seed and
no if it was a seven seat ah okay never
mind but it was a seventy the car was a
four seat
uh so he car gets choice that makes
sense
for some reason my head bit it was the
three seat because they all tied first
to eighth place with eight and a half
out of ten
but i i was remembering incorrectly
i think i thought that mama jarva was
the two and then but it was a three
but that was definitely not the case
okay
and the game has started hit car plus e4
we have
are we getting the berlin i doubt it no
we get this
ansi delayed exchange uh spanish here
and anthony berlin and vinnie needs to
move quickly
he needs to move well of course but he
needs to move quickly and i think that's
going to be his biggest problem
right now his car is going to use time
as a weapon and knight g5 doesn't have
to do anything this is
protected you just take back and what's
the situation
whoa hung up on did it went upon the
center
that was huge and vivid needs to fight
quickly because he is up
a clean pawn right now and he brings
queen back to e6 he wants to play f6 to
keep
his f5 no he's going aggressive here and
vin is actually ahead in the clock
wow the car blundered the e4 pawn and
now
can you play e4 can you just push that
through no he doesn't do it
i'm wondering when e4 is possible but he
this g
pawn is hanging in many variations
because a5 which both
allows to play a4 and gives his king an
outlet and now with g5 he's playing on
both sides of the board here
okay and he car is even on the clock
so when is e4 going to happen the queen
can be exchanged on
d5 but that fixes that is pawn structure
as we enter the
uh late middle game stages do not take
on f4 that blunders they broke on e6
but vince is using too much time and his
position is great but i don't like his
clock management right now
e4 what's this this knight's not hanging
knight c4
what's going on here queen takes f4 is
there some kind of e takes d3 because
the back rank mate no the queen covers
on
g1 so he brings queen back to c7 he just
does not
not have enough time i don't think he's
going to be
really trying to save this one but his
clock is not good
no no no no no his clock is really bad
for him
yeah there's gonna be a win for a car i
feel like oh wait d2
what just happened there and now it's
hikaru
taking d2 next but don't take this away
because queen takes d1 so he takes this
one he's queen g1
that is precision by hikaru and he's
going to win
on the board he wins on the clock hikaru
nakamura takes
this speed chess championship grand prix
it was a blunder in the early stages too
did it stole the pawn
and akaru just said yeah okay i
blundered it happens
right down the center here the uh queen
is behind the pawn so you can't take it
back
and still won the game so what a
performance by akari nakamura
even when it looks like he's in trouble
we're going to take a our last break and
when we return we'll bring his car on
get a quick interview with the speed
chess championship grand prix
[Music]
winner
and we are back with the speed chest
champion grand prix winner
hicary nakamura so i have to
congratulate you first and foremost for
qualifying for the speed chess
championship aren't you proud of
yourself
one second i apparently have to mute my
zoom
yeah okay can you hear me now i can hear
you
can you hear me
nope can't hear me all right nikaru
way way i'm doing something wrong one
second um
wait wait no no one side one one second
robert let me let me go back the other
way sorry
no no worries um okay
can you hear me i can hear you the whole
time can you hear me this is the last
one i'm trying this
let me let me reopen this sorry look um
now i'm muted in zoom 2. uh-oh can you
hear me though no yeah now i hear yes
sorry okay so now i think it's fine no i
think i
have to mute like the streamer figure
out which one is muted um and so forth
but yeah i think we're good now so
gotcha all right go ahead go ahead i was
congratulating you on as a joke for
qualifying for the speed chess
championship because you did win the
speech champion grand prix like the
total series
you just you're a monster like you just
nobody can stop you
how do you do it um you know i i mean i
think in general
uh i i i think in general um
mainly what i would say is that you just
play every game you take it one game at
a time basically
okay well how about the your decision in
the final
you made that quick draw which you've
done before when you think it optimizes
your winning chances against vidit you
just said let's make a draw and head to
bullet so
that looked like a little bit of
foresight by you yeah i mean i think the
thing is is that i felt against
probably against veda and parham
specifically they're two of the best
blitz players like who i could play
against
and um and so if i have the opportunity
to go into bullet i
probably should be a bigger favorite
there than i'm going to be in being
blitz
right and you certainly prove that to be
the case and when you drop that pawn
against evin there were you concerned
about the result or did you feel like
you would be able to bounce back because
that was a pretty important pawn
objectively in the position
yeah i mean i think at that point i was
i was a little bit
discombobulated everything was kind of
going weird because i tried to run an
ad and then like they started the game
right away then there was on board then
i tried to make a move and the game
started like five seconds later it's all
pretty
pretty random but i think again in
bullet more so than blitz you just you
just make moves and
i felt that um actually the game against
vedic wasn't the one that i thought was
close i think the game against parham
was the one
um where he thought for too long there
was this critical moment in the middle
game where i think he used like 20
seconds or 15 15 to 20 seconds for two
moves
and that was the game where he was up on
time and it's very very complicated and
i think that one was objectively a
little bit closer and tighter than
the one against vedic i just kept making
moves against vida and he just couldn't
keep up with the flow
yeah and obviously both of them are very
strong players
but so how do you train that like how do
you force yourself to make a move
you're just an example of it was
complicated he was a little ahead in
time
but then he spent 20 seconds so how can
you force yourself
to play a good move quickly rather than
try to find the
absolute best move i mean it's bullet
chests
time is money as the saying goes and um
you just try to move quickly and i
i think in general um like the one good
thing about position
against vita especially was that the the
way the position was
i didn't really have many things to
consider i had to try to
like maneuver my knight to c4 or play
like f4 when he tries g4 h4 on the
king's side and so the fact that i
didn't really have many moves to
consider
i think really helped me in terms of
just just playing moves because there
isn't much to do i'm down a pawn and
much worse
but you just make moves and hopefully
your opponent isn't as fast or they make
some mistakes and and vida uh he just
wasn't wasn't quite
fast enough at the end there yeah and
hikara throughout the
speeches champions grand prix you want
five knockout brackets so
pretty impressive there did you keep
track or did you
is that a surprise to you no i didn't
keep track i mean
the thing is most of the ones that i
played in i felt were at least two of
them were very random where i got to a
bad start i had to win like four or five
in a row at the end to
to get into the um to get into in into
the knockout so i knew i had won quite a
few
i didn't really pay close attention to
it though so um
you know you just play and i i felt that
i feel like in the head-to-head
especially to format a bullet
at the end um generally speaking i
should be the favorite against probably
anybody and i think i kind of proved
that
um based on how many of the knockouts i
won okay my final question for you is
now we know four more players who are
taking part in the speed chess
championship based on their grand prix
standings
and those are artemiev nerdy because
parham maxwell and hayek martirosian of
well i think
you're going to say our 10 minutes i'll
exclude him for the time being which of
those players has the best chance of
registering an upset in the speedchest
championship
i mean you say upset i'm i'm not sure
that i would say our tamiya
is an underdog that's why that's why i
took him out of the equation i i would
also make the argument i'm not honestly
sure that parham is an underdog either
out of those four guys um
so yeah i guess what i would say is in
general
um those first two i don't think are
gonna
be really be underdogs i think probably
notre beck is is the one who's most
likely to cause an upset
um though out of that group of four
because i consider par ham and artemia
to be at least
even if not favorites when they who
whomever they uh go up against the
speech house championship
so even if they're playing somebody like
mvl or wesley you say that
they're about level toss-up i i mean i
think parham and
and um parham and vladislav the other
but they're both very strong players i
think it's close they might be slight
underdogs
but they're not going to be big
underdogs okay now that's you know some
high praise we know from our tamil he's
made the semi-finals before that's no
surprise
but i guess uh by feed a classical
rating it's a different story than when
you get to the online especially
these quicker time controls so he carved
you know gotta thank you for joining us
the interview and congratulate you once
more you are the
champion of the speeches championship
grand prix you're the reigning speeches
champion so a lot of titles to bestow
upon you and we're very appreciative of
your time
yeah thank you that's fun all right
and there you have it the final
standings of the
speed chest champion grand prix hikaru
nakamura finishes
in a dominant first 137.5
points he made just as many points from
the
knockout bonus as he did from the swiss
score
and that's the difference look at that i
mean you have the players right after
him or temeo ferocious
abuse and parham maxoudlu they all
scored
almost as much as hikar did as their
swiss base score
but it was where in the knockout where
hikaru was just
an absolute monster winning five of them
and that's where his bonuses came from
and artemyev he qualifies feroceae has
already made his way through
by virtue of finishing second place in
the speeches championship super swiss
sorry kara won that
ferocious gets the second spot and that
allows heike marchi roshan to
sneak in as the fourth qualifier from
the grand prix in addition to
nerdy back abductor and parham magsudu
and reminded everybody that there will
be more qualification spot
on the line there's one in the speed
chess
invitational which will be happening in
the near future
you should you know follow chess.com
social media to
find out when that will be follow the
news reports but it has not yet been
confirmed as the date but
1250 first place prize as well as the
qualifications speech chess championship
and how else could you get the speeches
championship most of the spots are
away the top four from the grand prix
the winner of the
uh super swiss which ended up being
fedor save in second
nihal sarin from the jfcc and that
leaves one spot up for qualification
grabs
in the speedchest championship
invitational
on that note the grand prix has come to
a
conclusion it's been a really fun series
of events hikaru nakamura week in week
out
no matter who he faces no matter if he
drops an early game or not
he finds his way to the top and he is a
worthy champion we gotta
give all the credit in the world to
karna nakamura it's a bit of gujarati
today
for making it such a fun fight making it
to
the bullet tiebreaker where did it stole
upon but just
couldn't keep up on the clock until karu
won it
and that's all from chess.com for this
speech of champion grand prix i'm
grandmaster robert s until next time
keep enjoying the chest stay safe and
have a good one everybody
[Music]
you